Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Du ich habe Beschwerden bekommen das jetzt hier während unserer Sendung Straftaten durchgeführt werden sowas.
Na ja dann kann die Polizei ja eine Wache auf dem Metaebene Gelände errichten.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer
nein 301 daran muss ich mich jetzt erstmal gewöhnen es ist soweit wir haben ja die 300 Zusendung hinter uns gebracht und deswegen gehen wir jetzt in eine neue Ära.
Nämlich die Ära der 300er Sendung ja heute ist der 15.
My horse App 15. Mai erstaunlich sieht's ich fand es geradezu erstaunlich.
Welche Haushaltshilfe 315.
Eis ich habe schon oft bei ranero glaube ich gerade irgendwie am Start.
Alles alles um 1 Uhr verschoben typische winterkrankheiten ja nee 15. Mai und da sind wir wieder und haben eine ganz stinknormale Sendung für euch
nachdem wir wieder so ein wunderschönes Wochenende mit vielen von euch haben feiern dürfen bei logbuch-netzpolitik 300.
Ja das war doch schön.
Das war ganz toll und wollen wir uns aber gleich mal hier vorwegnehmen warum viele Leute da war wieder schön voll im Babylon.
Wir haben's dann auch anders als angedroht doch noch auf den letzten Metern geschafft
Aufzeichnung der ganzen Veranstaltung hinzubekommen ist nicht nur eine Audioaufzeichnung sauer noch eine Videoaufzeichnung dafür geht auf jeden Fall noch mal der Dank an das Wort vom cccb
die sich dann kurzfristig bemüht haben noch Technik zusammenzutragen und so können wir euch dann leben auch einen Mitschnitt präsentieren.
Nicht nur ein wir haben ja mehrere.
Das stimmt bestimmt.
Wir haben,
wir haben wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe den Mitschnitt des Gesprächs mit Cecile Leonard die haben den Mitschnitt des Gesprächs mit Klaus Landefeld die haben den Mitschnitt
der ist Familienduell und wir haben,
Tim die Leute warten darauf den Mitschnitt des live Zeichnens von Roland aber dein Mac mini Videoschnitt Mac mini,
spinnt bei dir ne.
Ja irgendwie hatte ich hier skurrile Freezes keine Ahnung was da los ist muss man noch mal gucken zuletzt ging es wieder ich hoffe dass ich das jetzt auch noch bald nachgeschoben bekomme und dann könnt ihr euch das auch noch mal anschauen.
Das ist das dass es glaube ich dass das der sehenswerteste Mitschnitte natürlich und jetzt kommt hier subscribe to Metaebene kann ich da nur sagen.
Denn das Video wird dort erscheinen und wir stellen fest dass der Tim als alter Podcaster auf YouTube noch nicht die Reichweite hat die ihm gebührt.
Und deswegen subscribed euch dort mal dann er reitet ihr nämlich auch hier die Video notification wenn dann endlich der Ablaut.
Derlei Zeichen Version stadtg.
Ja ich tue mir mich ja normalerweise nicht so viel auf YouTube war ich noch nie so richtig Spaß daran gefunden habe in irgendwelche Kameras rein zu starren und dabei heftig herum zu wedeln oder mehr um was anderes einfallen zu lassen aber für solche Mitschnitt das ist natürlich ganz.
Gehen auch Tim also mit anderen Worten um das ein bisschen positiver auszudrücken hey wenn ihr bei Tim liked in Sims 3,
dann müsst ihr keine Angst haben dass euch jeden Morgen mit ihrem welcher Werbung ins Gesicht wedelt.
Görtz.
Ich hatte ja jetzt ich hatte da werde ich Ihnen in einer der folgenden Sendung mal drüber sprechen ein bisschen Einblicke in die in die YouTube Sehne das war interessant aber der rede ich dann darüber wäre es wenn,
das Ei gelegt.
Genau vielleicht noch zu den T-Shirts wir haben ja ein paar hübsche T-Shirts für euch.
Sie war so geil.
Wetter XL.
Die waren geil sie waren geil.
Na diese sind auch immer noch geil
genau sehr wenige von euch konnten dann trotz Vorbestellung auf den letzten Metern doch nicht kommen den habe ich alles schon Kontakt aufgenommen den schick mir euch das noch zu alle anderen
werden aber auch noch in den Genuss kommen können wir werden in den nächsten Tagen nicht schätze mal so anfangen dieser Woche den Restbestand,
auch noch mal zum Versand anbieten das heißt falls ihr auch Lust habt so ein tolles logbuch-netzpolitik Shirt zu bekommen werde dir diese Gelegenheit bekommen könnte es online klicken und kriegt das dann schön ordentlich.
Kulturelle.
Öko Tex Textil genäht von
unter fairen Bedingungen ich weiß nicht von wem aber unter fairen Bedingungen alle möglichen Zertifizierung die man für Textilien bekommen kann und bedruckt in Berlin beim Mittelständler so das ist so gut habt ihr euch selten,
gefühlt ich glaube das einzige was ihr wir noch fairer und.
Und biologischer wäre wäre eurer Haut aber um die zu schonen ist dieses textildecke ich,
äußerst gut geeignet trägt auch nicht so dick auf ich habe meine Präferenz für Schwarz hier noch mal zu Rostock gebracht schwarz auf schwarz
da machst du nichts falsch passt zu allem ne wenn wir wenn man jetzt ich höre des Menschen auch immer angestrengter ihre Kleiderschränke sortieren ein Problem dass ich nie hatte.
Ja würdet ihr es gibt eine Technik die habe ich jetzt letztens kennengelernt wie man sein Kleiderschrank so sortiert das.
Dass man irgendwie verschiedene Outfits hat und da wurde mir dann erklärt also wenn man quasi ne wenn man drei Hosen hat und drei Oberteile,
ja das ist daraus eben entsprechend viele Kombinationen ableiten ja in denen man das tragen kann der mich 9 Uhr,
jede Hose zu ein Oberteil bzw der fährt sie vollständige Permutation auf jeden Fall ich war ich konnte dieser dieser Darstellung gar nicht folgen.
Weil bei mir passt sowieso alles zu Alpen der Trick also ist tragt einfach alles in schwarz ja und da könnt ihr wirklich passt wirklich alles zu einem Amazon Kleiderschrank gar nicht anders sortieren ihr greift einfach das erste was da drin ist,
auf der Hose Seite und das erste was er drin ist auf der T-Shirts Seite und es passt immer ja Tipp vom.
Adresse Star ja der ich will ja für meinen Kleidung Stil.
Also ich bin mir sicher unsere Nerd lastige oral Gemeinschaft ist auf die Idee noch nie gekommen.
Also welche Weise Leute hat gucken vielleicht doch nicht auf die Idee gekommen.
Das geht auch im übrigen mit allen anderen Farben also tschüss.
Sieht allerdings natürlich ich der Tipp ist es geht mit allen anderen Farben aber alle anderen Farben mit schwarz geht auch immer ja
also wenn du jetzt wenn jetzt hast du kaufst dir grün und gelb ja da hast du natürlich Schwierigkeiten das zu kombinieren oder brauchst halt ein gewisses Standing und das zu kombinieren also gewisse Selbstsicherheit
schwarz mit grün schwarz mit gelb geht immer wobei einige Schalker widersprechen würden.
Was dieses alles sagen möchte ist wenn es einfach halten wollt holt euch einfach ein Logbuch Netzpolitik Shirt.
Das passt zu allem passen herausfordern.
Ende der Entente.
Die logbuch-netzpolitik Challenge finde etwas wozu dieses T-Shirt nicht passt.
Oh Mann also ich Metaebene gibt es gibt sich immer mit Stolz werbefrei zu sein wo das noch weiter treiben wenn durchbreche ich diese Regel.
Oh ja jetzt die Mails habe ich auch gelesen so dann kommen wir machen wir Werbung für die Europawahl.
Genau,
weil das muss sein ist nämlich demnächst und zwar in Deutschland am 26.Mai ich weiß gerade gar nicht wie das in Österreich ist ob die auch auf dem Sonntag wählen ich vermute es mal weiß es aber gerade nicht
andere Länder sind ja teilweise etwas früher dran Großbritannien z.b. muss schon am 23.Mai rei.
Am warum auch immer die da der Meinung sind man müsste Wahlen auf dem Werktag legen aber es ist eine andere Diskussion.
War noch auf der linken Straßenseite zur Wahl.
Ja ich habe ohnehin Briefwahl beantragt und ich habe es einfach mal überall beantragt wo es möglich war noch total 100% Rücklauf bekommen und jetzt blicke ich hier auf diesen 20km schon Wahlzettel,
Deutschlands und auf den etwas kürzer gehaltenen.
PayPal von UK und habe jetzt sozusagen die freie Auswahl ich kann mich jetzt entscheiden in dem ein Land oder einem anderen Land zu wählen.
In in Katalonien hast du noch keine Staatsbürgerschaft beantragt viatim sos will in echter Europeade collect them all.
Original auf der Welt überall ja das so weit bin ich noch nicht mal gucken will.
Mach mir aber bitte nicht hier diesen Giovanni di Lorenzo und Seele in zwei Ländern davon.
Nein das will ich natürlich niemals tuen aber ich muss mich halt entscheiden das ist kannst du das Hand weil es eigentlich in beiden durchaus.
Ja also es würde in beiden Ländern Sinn machen ne und,
mir würde jetzt zusammen stand heute sowie die Wahl in Großbritannien sogar noch einen Hauch leichter fallen als in Deutschland ich bin noch unentschlossen.
Der Trend geht zur zweit halten.
Zweitstimme mal anders.
So dann haben wir diese Werbung hinter uns jetzt wollte ich eigentlich zu Beginn etwas Neues einführen nehme ich das ja einfach mal zurück in der Sendung euch sagen,
was wir besprechen wollen und zwar wollen wir heute sprechen über das Fusion-Festival.
Genau das muss auf jeden Fall mal machen Feedback kann man natürlich noch.
Über die Republik A19 über den WhatsApp NSA Hack über Sicherheitslücken bei Videokameras des Herstellers Abus.
Über Sperrungen auf Twitter über einen Hack bei mehreren oder mehrere Hacks bei mehreren Antivirenhersteller der Zerschlagung von Facebook.
Abend eben Wallstreet market der nun sein Ende gefunden hat eine Darknet Plattform und wir halten euch auf dem laufenden wie es Chelsea Manning und Julien Assange ergeht also bleiben Sie bitte dran.
Genau.
Und davor beginnen wir natürlich mit dem Vieh
Damerow diesmal zwei Feedback ausgesucht eines wurde sehr vehement bei Twitter vorgetragen und dann auch in die Kommentare gegossen zwar Elli sich ja einen Kommentar vor von Mark Mark
schreibt uns dass er sich sehr geärgert hat das Graffiti sprühen.
In der LLP 300 ohne Kritik behandelt wurde.
Wir lassen sich die Arbeit in eurem Podcast aufklären und da halten dafür hut ab auch die Aktion des Apps sind größtenteils toll und treuen im bemerkenswerten bemerkenswerterweise die Gesellschaft hier sehen der Mark anders als auf Twitter
verwendet er hier die Sandwich Technik wo man erst mit einem Kompliment anfängt dann den Dolch rein Rand und dann am Ende noch mal ein nettes Wort verliert jetzt also die Kritik
allerdings kann ich der Verharmlosung von Kunst auf fremden Eigentum dem ihr über zehn Minuten mit kaum versteckte Anerkennung gewidmet habt den ihr über zehn Minuten mit kaum versteckter Anerkennung gewidmet hat in keinster Weise zustimmen.
Ob die erzeugten Inhalte Kunst sind
muss man nicht mehr diskutieren wenn sie fremdes Eigentum bis zur Unbrauchbarkeit beeinträchtigt niemand möchte in einem Zug fahren durch dessen Fenster man nicht mehr durchschauen kann und für den künstler relevante Dinge wie 25,
Techno AG prmg die auf den Fahrzeugen draufstehen muss der Betriebs Eisenbahner unbedingt wissen.
Um das Fahrzeug sicher fahren zu können also der Punkt ist wenn darüber wenn diese Aufschrift überschrieben ist dann,
kann der kann das Fahrzeug nicht mehr sicher geführt werden ehrenamtlich lackierte Züge erzeugen jeden Monat sechsstellige Schäden diese Geldbeträge könnte man auch für Reparatur von Schulen.
Oder ein attraktiveres Verkehrsangebot ausgeben damit mehr Leute vom Auto auf die Bahn umsteigen,
das als ehrenamtliche Kunst zu bezeichnen entwertet die heutige Arbeit von Künstlerin und von Ehrenamtlern die sich z.b. um alte Leute kümmern oder das Vereinsleben örtlicher Sportvereine schmeißen,
wie würdet ihr euch fühlen wenn jemand über Nacht euer Auto oder Firmenschild der Metaebene ehrenamtlich lackiert
okay ich glaube ja. Ist ja drüber gemacht worden ich sage einfach nur ich habe gar kein Auto aber mein Fahrrad ehrenamtlich zu lackieren finde ich auch nicht in Ordnung.
Endet damit die Freiheit der Kunst endet wo das Eigentum anderer beginnt,
so jetzt denke ich ist hier ausreichend rübergebracht worden dass der Mark das Lackieren von Zügen die nicht gut findet die Kritik,
die an uns gerichtet wird es aber wir hätten diese Schilderung mit Anerkennung.
Irgendwie wahrgenommen und nicht,
die Gelegenheit ergriffen uns nun kritisch dazu zu äußern dass wir Sachbeschädigungen,
nicht in Ordnung finden oder Kunst keine Kunst mehr ist wenn sie auf dem Eigentum anderer stattfindet,
da gibt's denn entscheiden Unterschied wie ich es verstehe wie ein Interview durchzuführen ist das hat hier nichts mit Anerkennung zu tun sondern etwas,
ein Einblick wir führen die Interviews nicht.
Damit wir den Interview Interviewten irgendwie erklären was sie falsch machen und wir richtiger finden sondern wir führen solche Interviews um Einblicke zu erhalten.
Wir sind also nicht bei ihnen einer Podiumsdiskussion oder bei Anne Will wo es darum geht Recht zu haben sollen wir sind hier in unserem Sendung spezifisch dabei Menschen.
Eine Möglichkeit zu geben ihre Sicht und ihre Erfahrungen ihre Erfahrungen darzustellen und andere Meinung sind da herzlich willkommen.
Sind notwendig und sind auch spannend aber,
LMP 300va nicht unter dem Titel Graffiti Fluch oder Segen Graffiti oder soll man es lassen Graffiti Kunst oder Sachbeschädigung,
das sind nämlich uninteressante fragen weil jemand seine Meinung ändern wird Mark du wirst deine Meinung nicht ändern dass du gerade IT scheiße findest sie wird ihre Meinung oder ihre Vergangenheit nicht ändern dass sie das gemacht hat.
Aber ich denke das hoffentlich auch du einen interessanten Einblick darein gewonnen hast wie sie darüber gedacht hat als sie es gemacht hat und wie sie das erlebt hat
ja du wirst deine Meinung nicht ändern sie wird ihre Meinung nicht ändern aber an deiner emotionalen Reaktion sehe ich sowas auch nicht der einzige der da so drauf reagiert hat sehe ich das dieser Einblick euch,
immerhin berührt hat und genau das,
ist das Ziel eines solchen Gespräches und das mache ich nicht dadurch kaputt dass ich dann mit erhobenem Finger irgendwelche Menschen belehre dass das wo irgendwie die Grenzen der Kunst sind so man denn die Meinung vertritt dass es solche,
Gerber.
Das alles richtig was du sagst wenn ich mit dem noch hinzufügen das.
Ist dieser Teil war ja nun auch der Teil wo wir so ein bisschen mal einfach ihrer Vergangenheit beleuchtet haben und unser Ziel auf dieser Veranstaltung war natürlich auch ganz klar, von Anfang an so gesagt,
wir wollen Aktivisten vorstellen und wir wollen herausfinden wie Sie das sehen welche
Entscheidung welcher Erlebnisse in ihrem Leben ihren Weg geprägt haben ja und warum sie später die Dinge getan haben auf die Art und Weise wie sie sie getan haben zu und da gehört das einfach fest dazu.
In insta Sonne in diesem Fall total ne.
Besondere in in in in diesem Fall ne und ich waren in gewisser Hinsicht freue ich mich eigentlich auch über so ein Feedback weil und das ist auch glaube ich bei,
CPs und bei vielen anderen Künstlern auch so ein bisschen so ein Unterthema Kunst die nicht wehtut und die nicht irgendwie auch Reaktionen hervorbringt.
Ist irgendwie kann dann auch glaube ich bisschen weg
ja immer da wenn man Kunst nur als ja ich mache hier was schönes das kann ich mir da die Wand hängen nachdem ich 300 € dafür bezahlt habe abgespeichert das ist glaube ich nicht die Art von Kunst von der sie gesprochen hat und.
Die wir dort auch porträtiert haben Sahnesauce einen eine Kunstlinse im aktivistischen Kontext die eben versucht Missstände in unserer Gesellschaft aufzuzeigen und bisschen den Finger in die Wunde zu legen.
Und das sind nicht selten Leute die
auch in ihrer Vergangenheit auch schon immer so ein Tanz auf der Rasierklinge und unternommen haben und immer ein gespanntes Verhältnis der Gesellschaft haben was ja jetzt auch keine unidirektionale Geschichte es ist ja nicht so dass sie jetzt und wie ein böser Mensch ist und deswegen jetzt beschlossen hat,
alles zu vernichten was ihr unter die Sprühflasche kommt,
das ganze ist ja auch eine Reaktion darauf wie die Gesellschaft mit ihr und mit den Themen die für Sie wichtig ist umgegangen ist,
möchtest ja keine reine Aktion das ist ja auch immer eine Reaktion und da muss man natürlich auch mal reflektieren was
was führt denn sozusagen auch dazu dass Leute eine andere Auffassung von gemeinschaftlichen Eigentum und gemeinschaftlichen Guthaben oder eine andere Auffassung darüber entwickeln wie man damit umzugehen hat oder nicht umzugehen hat das sind ja auch alles Faktoren die hier mit rein spielen also,
ich bin sehr froh und sehr glücklich darüber wir dieses Gespräch
gelaufen ist ich finde das hat sehr viele Einblicke gebracht und wir hatten auch sehr schnell das Feedback
noch auf der Veranstaltung bekommen somit da hätten wir auch noch mal eine Stunde dranhängen können das stimmt natürlich aber wir hatten hier auch einen zeitlichen Rahmen die wir nicht komplett sprengen wollen.
Einschließlich mich an halte ich für das echte ich eines der gelungenen Interviews und Gespräche die wären logbuch-netzpolitik hatten,
genau,
das war das Ziel und genau diese diese ewige Werte Reih und man muss sich jetzt von allem distanzieren sorry das ist mir sowas von.
Ja
habe ich überhaupt kein Interesse dran ja weil das den den Einblick verhindert und da gibt's gerade ein YouTube-Video was irgendwie kursiert
äußerst spannend wo nämlich der Jan Böhmermann irgendwie eine eine Ausstellung in Österreich macht über
Autoritarismus Gläubigkeit also ihr wir.
Autoritätsgläubigkeit und dann natürlich relativ viele und harsche Nazivergleiche zieht.
Und indem in einem Interview mit dem ORF irgendwie auch so sagt ja dürft ihr eigentlich noch schreiben was ihr wollt oder erhaben machen soll euch jetzt hier auch bald schon dicht Ja und,
das wird ausgestrahlt in einer Kunst und Kultur Sendung wo dieser Satiriker mit seiner offenkundig satirischen Ausstellung behandelt wird und am Ende gibt dieser gibt der ORF sich die Blöße.
Sich vor dem zu distanzieren ja und genau diese Blöße bin ich nicht bereit,
mir in logbuch-netzpolitik zu geben indem ich mich da blöd hinstelle und unsere Sendungs Gäste belehre wie sie irgendwie bessere deutsche werden könnten oder so ja also da bin ich bin ich entschieden dagegen,
weil das entschieden den Austausch und die Diskussion Hemd wenn man die ganze Zeit nur mit irgendwelchen.
Ausgestreckten Zeigefinger in rumrennt und sagt das darf aber nicht sein statt sich einfach mal die Sachen an zur deswegen empfehle ich an dieser Stelle.
Das metrolaut spezialzüge Anlagen.
Für alle die sich noch ein bisschen länger über Graffiti Sprüher ärgern wollen weil relativ langes Interview mit einem notorischen,
Graffiti sprühen der nicht nur im Graffiti sprühen Seich mal die Grenzen der.
Des guten Geschmacks und der Legalität verlässt,
und als ich das gehört habe muss ich sagen also ein einfach einen Einblick der einen auch nicht mehr loslässt ja und das wäre auch so ein Gespräch wäre komplett,
gewesen wenn der Interviewer an der Stelle die ganze Zeit nur gesagt hätte aber das ist doch verboten und das geht doch.
Insofern bitte bitte bitte.
Allgemein nimmt auch mal Einblicke ihr könnt eure Meinung behalten niemand verlangt von euch dass ihr jetzt Züge an sprüht der sollt ihr auch nicht nämlich verboten aber die Augen und die Ohren für Menschen offen zu haben die das tun.
Super sich darüber zu ärgern super aber sich über uns zu ärgern wie wir dieses Gespräch geführt haben das Fass ich ehrlich gesagt eher als Kompliment.
Und überhaupt ihr uns kritisieren bekommen in 1.
Gräber Versuche.
Also schon sehen was davon ab.
Soviel würde ich sagen zum Feedback und dann könnten wir jetzt endlich zum Thema kommt.
Mir ist gerade noch dabei noch Feedback.
Genau das habe ich gerade rausgenommen und deswegen so schön übergeleitet mit soviel zum Feedback.
Achso habe ich aber nicht gesehen dass du es rausgenommen hast ja wir kommen zu einem Festival.
Da ist jetzt schon einiges drüber berichtet worden aber ich wollte vielleicht mal gleich zu Anfang noch mal kurz erklären worum es sich da eigentlich handelt die Rede ist natürlich von der Fusion.
Diffusion ist ein relativ groß gewachsen ist Festival was in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
in der Nähe der Müritz bei Morton lenzenalm in der Nähe oder nudelbacher Nachbarschaft zu einem Flughafen stattfindet es handelt sich dabei auch um das Gelände eines ehemaligen
Club russischen Militärflughafen.
Mit vielen Hangars ist Hitler wo in den letzten 22 Jahren sich dort eine riesige Alternativkultur aufgebaut hat da findet das.
Das findet auch nicht immer nur dieses eine Festival dort shtatzanis ist ein permanenter Ort geworden unter dem Namen Kulturkosmos bekannt und reicht eben weit in die deutsche Techno,
Gemeinschaft Geschichte zurück ich habe das
von Anfang an begleiten dürfen ja durch Zufall habe ich die allererste Veranstaltung von den Leuten noch damals noch in Hamburg mitbekommen.
Da ist mir so ein bisschen Planten un Blomen rum und das war so dieser Aufbruchs seit Anfang der 90er Jahre wo einfach.
Ja Techno neues Lebensgefühl
losgetreten hat nach breite T3 das muss man alles gar nicht groß erwähnen speziellen Hamburg allerdings hat sich eben diese Openair Kultur besonders hervorgetan
und als dann so die Räume auch schon ein bisschen über nutzt waren in Hamburg
gab es dann eben diesen tragen in den Osten wohl natürlich extrem viele Räume und damit auch Freiräume sich an Boden und dann auf dieses Gelände gekommen.
Und ich war auf der ersten Flusen ab das von den ersten Jahren eigentlich durchgehend begleitet und es war
ein Wort ein ein ein ein Ort der totalen Freiheit
wo Leute friedlich zusammen kamen und dann einfach über die Jahre dort eine Party Kultur weiterentwickelt haben die sich ins Unfassbare entwickelt hat difusion ist seit.
Einigen Jahren habe ich auch mit Abstand die größte Veranstaltung dieser a,
auf jeden Fall in Deutschland wenn ich sogar europaweit und könnte sogar fast sagen es ist fast die einzige Veranstaltung dieser Art weil in dieser Art wie sie durchgeführt wird,
ja weiß wie wird es nicht viel einfallen wo sich in ähnlicher Art und Weise so viel Kreativität Raum,
schafft,
wer mir hier oft schon auch über den Kongress geredet und darüber wieder Kongress auch davon lebt aus der eigenen Community heraus entwickelt worden zu sein und auch regelmäßig durch freiwillige überhaupt erst
durchführbar gemacht wird ähnlich verhält es sich auf der Fusion das ist nicht so dass es da ein Veranstalter Team gibt die
da was hinsetzen und dann kommen die Gäste haben ihren Spaß haben den Eintritt bezahlt und fahren wieder nach Hause was ist und so ein Prozess viele viele viele viele viele Gruppen also weiß gar nicht wie groß die Zahl der Leute sind die dort konkret etwas
tun und umge dafür sorgen bei der Fuzion aber ist dass das ist eine feine in denen deutlich vierstellige Zahl.
Also sind ich ganz kurz sagen weil ich die Zahlen alle kenne um um die etwas über 200 unterschiedliche Gruppen die dazu beitragen.
Die dann insgesamt,
auf eine Menge von ungefähr 10.000 Personen führen die zu dem Gelingen dieses Festivals beitragen das ist jetzt dann irgendwie ne Küche
Flora XY was weiß ich Massage area und was da so alles bei entsteht.
Und das ist hier also das ist halt dieses Ausmaß der Fusion ich würde vor allem noch ein bisschen.
Darauf eingehen wenn du sagst sowas bei der ersten fusion wie viele Leute waren das denn.
Genau kann ich das ja höchstens also so in der Größenordnung auf jeden Fall.
Und heute ist die Fusion seit ein paar Jahren zieht die 70.000.
Besucherin an na das bzw zieht auch mehr an aber verkauft eben nur so kann nur so viele
Personen auf das auf das Veranstaltungsgelände lassen die haben also dieses
dieses Gelände wird da vom Kulturkosmos eV dauerhaft bespielt für das Fusion-Festival wird der angrenzende Flugplatz noch mit hinzu gemietet.
Um da Menschen kämpfen zu lassen.
Und ansonsten glaube ich was sehr seltener Erwähnung findet ist das der Kulturkosmos ja nicht nur dieses Fusion-Festival ausrichtet sondern,
alle zwei Jahre auch das Theaterfestival et tension.
Was auch ebenso wie das yishan Festival halt über die,
Jahre sich einen ein international einzigartigen Ruf erarbeitet hat auf aufgrund seiner international einzigartigen Qualität
Programmes und der der Auswahl die dort stattfindet also da wird dann wirklich mal Menschen vor 20 Jahren begonnen etwas aufzubauen.
Das jetzt da oft eben die ganze Zeit pflegen die ganze Zeit ausbauen und da die die Region stärken.
Genau und und wer von euch auf der Fuß noch nicht wahr oder vielleicht auch noch nichts davon gehört hat nur damit ihr euch das mal vorstellen könntest ist also ein,
unfassbar großes Gelände wenn man da so langsam durch schlendern dann braucht man ungefähr eine Stunde von der einen Seite bis zur anderen wenn man es überhaupt in dieser Stunde schafft weil
aber soviel zu sehen ist und so viel passiert und so viel bunte Menschen um einen herum sind das man wahrscheinlich eher zwei oder drei Stunden braucht bis man von der einen Seite bis er angekommen ist
aber
da gibt es halt keine Coca-Cola wanna da gibt's keinen irgendwie Red Bull Tower wo um viel Leute in Wasserbecken springen dann findet einfach keinerlei kommerzielle Aktivität keinerlei Werbung nichts start
alles was dort ist ist von den Leuten selbst von diesem zweihundert Gruppen die Du schon erwähnt hast und man man merkt es
einfach an der Schönheit von allem von der Kreativität der Installation der Kunstsachen wie die Leute drauf sind das Gefühl ist einfach enorm sprich die schulischen ist ein ganz besonderer Ort
und jetzt steht diese Fusion unter Beschuss.
Ja ich.
Wie Tim gerade schon sagte wir haben halt wir haben die ein oder andere Verbindung zu der Fusion eine dieser dieser 200 Gruppen.
Ist eben auch in Anführungszeichen der CTC und wo unterschiedliche
ja ich sagte Gruppen innerhalb des CCC zum zum Gelingen des Festivals beitragen dass
geht mit so Sachen los wie elektronische Netzwerkinfrastruktur dort bereitzustellen und zu pflegen Diffusion hat auch,
Inhalte also ein das sogenannte Content welches regelmäßig vom CCC Wok,
betreut und gestreamt wird als sie machen da die Technik Live-Übertragung Aufzeichnung also ihr findet.
Quasi von den gleichen Leuten die euch die LMP 300 bringen die bringen euch auch dann halt dass das Fusion Content im im,
so zum Zeitpunkt des Festivals und diese Veranstaltung geht auch natürlich weit darüber hinaus.
Ein ein Techno Festival ist eben durch die durch die politische Haltung durch die politischen Angebote die dort gemacht wenn 70.000 Leute auf so einen Acker kommen.
Dann geht das natürlich nicht ohne sich über die Sicherheit dieser Zusammenkunft Gedanken gemacht zu haben und ich finde sehr wichtig an dieser Stelle einfach mal zu sagen wenn da eben 10000,
ehrenamtliche Mitarbeiter dieses Ding aufstellen dann entspricht das einem Betreuungsschlüssel von 1 zu 7.
Das ist also besser als als jede Kita wie du da die Durchdringung hast,
von Menschen die sich mal verantwortlich sind die Verständnis haben die für Sicherheit sorgen aber gleichzeitig hat das Ding natürlich ärztliche Versorgung vom Roten Kreuz Arbeit Arbeiter-Samariter-Bund.
Meine irgendwie sowas wie 160 medizinische Kräfte die dann da vor Ort sind und im Notfall,
sogar Operationen durchführen zu können so ungefähr also es wird ja nicht auf die leichte Schulter genommen
dummerweise stellt sich aber fest dass es stellt sich aber heraus dass die Leute mehr Kafkas die medizinische Versorgung ist hier so gut ich gehe mal zu meinem jährlichen Checkup dahin weil,
auf der Fuzion eben nichts nix großartiges passiert und diese Ärzte größtenteils damit beschäftigt sind irgendwie Pflaster auszugeben oder mal zugucken
ich habe da seit längerer Zeit die sind Fleck hinten am Rücken könnt ihr euch den mal anschauen so ungefähr ja.
Brandschutz ist natürlich da du hast die Feuerwehr an Ort und Stelle du hast auch ein Security Team.
Was tatsächlich ein bisschen nicht so also ist nicht so einfach ein einziger t-team zu finden das,
auf einer solchen Veranstaltung eben sich auch der,
der Kultur anpassen Diffusion gewachsen von eben 1000 auf 70000 Leute in moderatem Wachstum ab und zu auch mal größeren Schritten.
Hat natürlich also ich würde sagen das Sicherheitskonzept basiert.
Vielmehr auf der auf der Kultur.
Der Eigenverantwortung und der gegenseitigen Rücksichtnahme der Teilnehmerin als jetzt auf irgendeinem.
Stiernacken wir geben dir ansagen Konzept und das natürlich.
Als Phänomen auch erstens schwer zu beschreiben andererseits auch schwer zu.
Verstehen wenn man sich überlegt dass du an anderen Stellen unter anderen Kontexten viel weniger Menschen auf eine Straße bringen musst
oder an einen Ort bringen muss bis die anfangen sich gegenseitig auf die Fresse zu hauen ja nimm nimm ein Fußballspiel nimm ein durchschnittliches Rockkonzert nimm,
eine Demonstration wo es unter Umständen früher oder später zu Auseinandersetzungen kommt.
Und das ist natürlich auch psychologischen sehr interessanter sehr interessantes Phänomen dass du hier seit eben.
20 Jahren diese Menschen zusammenkommen und es da so gut wie nie.
Zu irgendwelchen gewaltsamen Auseinandersetzung kommt natürlich kommt das auch regelmäßig,
auf der Fusion irgendwie mal zu einer Rangelei oder auch einer Schlägerei wenn du das aber vergleichst mit den 70.000 Menschen die dort sind dann sind eben die anzahl der,
hör dort stattfinden Strafanzeigen oder Verletzung eben in so einem lächerlich einstelligen Bereich was im Prinzip.
Offen Berlin alle Berlin-Alexanderplatz wo Menschen einfach nur Langlaufen passiert mehr.
Es ist im übrigen auch die Einschätzung der örtlichen Polizei dass dort in den letzten Jahren deutlich weniger passiert ist als auf jedem durchschnittlichen Dorffest.
Also es ist gibt ein ein schönes Beispiel das Baumblütenfest in Werder an der Havel
ja das hat jetzt ist jetzt glaube ich auch wieder stattgefunden da wird den Leuten hat irgendwie Bier und Wein gegeben und die darfst du regelmäßig irgendwie so Massenschlägereien weil die ganzen Leute alkoholisiert sind und eben.
So blöd das klingt unter einer anderen Kultur zusammen kommen ja und dann geht das eben schief und dann hast du da Polizei Großeinsätze und so weiter.
Worauf ich hinaus will sie auch beim Kongress sorgt die Fusion mit allen möglichen Teams für Sicherheit ja ich betone das deshalb weil.
Jetzt öffentlich von der Polizei das Sicherheitskonzept der Fusion.
In Zweifel gezogen wird die haben Teams die in Fällen von Übergriffe in Feencon von Konflikten auf die Leute achten da wo man schwimmen darf und darüber nicht schwimmen darf,
Rettungsschwimmerin das ganze Ding ist eine Fußgängerzone für Leute die irgendwie von ihren Eindrücken überfordert sind oder Drogen genommen haben gibt's,
professionelle Betreuungen also da ist einfach an alles gedacht was du haben kannst besonders geil für Dich gern sogar eine Tierpsychologin.
Weil entgegen der Empfehlung und entgegen des Rates Menschen z.b. Tiere dort mit hinbringen und die Tiere dann durchdrehen dann brauchst du eine Tierpsychologin die sich um das Tier kümmert auf dem Weg ins.
Ins Tierasyl oder wie heißen die Tierschutz Tierheim Tierheim genommen.
Sie hasst dich.
Ja
So und jetzt kommen wir zu. So werden jetzt gesagt.
CCC ist der länger Zeit rennt verbunden warum interessiert das jetzt logbuch-netzpolitik naja weil nun folgendes passiert ist erstens.
Die Polizei hat sich jetzt dieser Sache angenommen
zweitens der Kulturkosmos der dieses Festival veranstaltet macht weder Werbung für andere noch Werbung für sich selber und es deshalb auch nicht besonders erfahren in der Pressearbeit.
Und hat sich da aus den Fusion Sympathisanten und Mitwirkenden und UnterstützerInnen deshalb ein
Team zur Medienarbeit zusammengestellt indem ich auch Mitglied bin solche betreuungs Konflikte solche Interessenkonflikte muss man ja durchaus transparent machen.
Beilmann
dazu sagen muss dass die Polizei sich natürlich dieser Veranstaltung schon immer angenommen hat es ja nicht so dass hier 22 Jahre lang diese Veranstaltung stattfand und die Polizei hat nicht interessiert sondern natürlich war die Polizei auch immer präsent aber eben.
Außerhalb des Geländes
es sei denn es kam zu irgendwelchen Vorfällen Voda natürlich die Polizei auch immer auf das Gelände gelassen wurde also wenn es jetzt zu einer Straftat
kam oder in irgendeiner Form aus anderen Gründen der Eingriff von der Polizei ist auch erforderlich war
dann kam die Polizei natürlich auch das Gelände hat ihren Einsatz gemacht fertig und dann war sie auch wieder weg.
Genau außerdem denke ich auch wichtig zu erwähnen die Polizei führt beim Fusion-Festival sowohl bei der zu Zeiten der Einreise insbesondere aber bei der
Abreise Verkehrskontrollen durch das finde ich sehr gut dass das gemacht wird weil das,
Grund hätte ich natürlich niemanden zu empfehlen ist sich auch so ein Festival unter Umständen mit Alkohol volllaufen zu lassen oder auch wenn sie nur nüchtern bleiben die wenig zu schlafen.
Und daneben übermüdet mit Restalkohol oder anderen nachweisbaren Substanzen noch im.
Er sich ins Fahrzeug zu setzen da werden regelmäßig ich glaube so um die.
200 Personen dann rausgezogen,
wenn man den Polizeistatistiken an dieser Stelle Glauben schenkt was natürlich von 70000 immer noch ein verschwindend geringer Anteil ist denn noch natürlich in Riesenproblem ja deswegen haben
hat der Kulturkosmos glaube ich schon als it off wahrscheinlich seit 10 Jahren.
Bieten sie denn den Bass Liner an und ermutigen alle ihre Besucherinnen mit Bussen anzureisen um eben hier die Gefahr für den Straßenverkehr einzuschränken einzudämmen und die Leute.
Da eben auf die sicheren und verantwortungsvollen Alternativen zu setzen muss aber auch sagen ganz kurz noch ich muss aber auch sagen wenn,
Polizeikontrollen stattfinden und Menschen mit Wisch testen oder mit Bluttest auf Drogen getestet werden.
Dann sticht spezifisch eine Droge in ihrer Nachweisbarkeit ganz besonders ekelhaft hervor und das ist kiffen,
Jan Wer kifft das Zeug ist einfach wochenlang nachweisbar,
wenn also die Polizeistatistiken sagen hier wir haben Einfluss bei so vielen Menschen festgestellt,
dann hast du relativ viel darunter Menschen die einfach
von mir aus vielleicht zwei Tage vorher zum letzten Mal gekifft haben die also jetzt nicht notwendigerweise unter hartem Einfluss dieser Droge
da am Steuer saßen wenn bei anderen Substanzen die Menschen zu sich nehmen wird diese Nachweiszeiten sehr viel kürzer
das heißt die nehmen was was ich Droge XY am Freitag setzen sich am Montag ins Auto und fahren ohne irgendwelche Probleme durch eine Polizeikontrolle weil sie eben vollkommen nüchtern sind wer gekifft hat ist im Zweifelsfall ebenso nüchtern und fahrtauglich
Schnitt bei dem schlagen aber dann diese Tests an.
So dass auch hier sei mal diese Zahl von von 200 Menschen bei denen Substanzen nachgewiesen werden laut Polizeistatistiken noch mal.
Eben relativiert werden muss was die Gefährdung der Straße.
Was er gerade erwähnt dass
ein Angebot gemacht wird mit Bussen dass wir nicht nur gemacht das wird auch angenommen also wäre derzeit der Fuzion handelt es sich bei diesem Gelände quasi um den größten Busbahnhof Europas,
irgendwo fahren so viele Busse die komplette Bus
Preise Kapazität Deutschland mindestens ist aufgekauft für diese Veranstaltung einen extrem großer Teil der Leute kommt mit Bussen
und anderen organisierten Fadenzug macht da gar nicht so viel aus die Züge sind immer rappelvoll aber da gibt's auch nicht soviel Kapazität also das funktioniert.
Die werden der werden Sonderzüge eingesetzt.
Ja aber es ist trotzdem ich bin damit auch schon paar mal gefahren es ist voll es ist schwierig
die Busse deckender sehr viel mehr ab ist aber nur so das nicht extrem viel in die Individualverkehr stattfinden natürlich Reisen auch viele Leute im Auto an da gibt's dann auch Parkplätze aber das sind jetzt nicht
die 70.000 also das Intercom nicht so viele Autos bei raus wie bei einem Fußballspiel wo 70.000 dorthin kommen.
So dann sind wir jetzt endlich in der in der aktuellen nachrichten dage dieses Festival findet also seit 22 Jahren mit einer Unterbrechung ich glaube 2018 hat die Fusion 2017 hat Diffusion nicht stattgefunden.
Und Ende 2016 wird in Neubrandenburg Mecklenburg-Vorpommern ein neuer Polizeipräsident installiert und der erhebt jetzt.
Eigentlich schon im November 2018 seine Stimme und sagt so der muss das jetzt lange genug angeschaut hier findet eine Massenveranstaltung statt.
Und ich möchte diese Veranstaltung bitte mit,
Hilfe meiner Polizeikräfte kontrollieren was heißt kontrollieren kontrollieren heißt nicht die Kontrollen außen oder ne auf Zuruf oder auf auf anrufe auf das Gelände kommen sondern.
Er sagt er möchte eine eigene Polizeiwache auf dem Gelände haben Privatgelände des Veranstalters.
Er möchte von dieser eigens zu errichten im Polizeiwache das Gelände bestreifen also Patrouillen auf diesem Festivalgelände laufen lassen sowohl in Zivile als auch in Uniform.
Und dann stellt sich im weiteren Verlauf heraus dass er dafür 1100 Beamtinnen und Beamte nach Lärz schaffen möchte.
Und jetzt kommt der spannende. Die Polizei hat einen Hebel.
Den Sie verwenden kann um eine solche Auflage durchzudrücken und das ist die Zustimmung zum Sicherheitskonzept eine solche Veranstaltung.
Wird natürlich bei der beim Ordnungsamt angemeldet,
und wird dann genehmigt oder eben nicht genehmigt und Teil dieses Genehmigungsprozess ist ist eine ganze Menge an Bürokratie natürlich du musst also quasi nachweisen dass du
die notwendigen Kapazitäten und Konzepte hast um diese Veranstaltung durchzuführen und dazu gehört unter anderem auch seid.
Einigen Jahren Auslöser war das Loveparade Unglück in Duisburg dass es jetzt verpflichtend ist das Vorlegen eines Sicherheitskonzept.
Das machen wir auch beim Camp und das machen wir auch beim Kongress wo also erklärt wird folgende gefahren.
Haben sie ja oder folgende Risiken haben wir für diese Veranstaltung identifiziert.
Und folgende Maßnahmen haben die ergriffen um diese Risiken zu managen ihr habt also das geht dann los mit was weiß ich was machen wir bei Unwetter,
ja oder was machen wir und so weiter dann seine muss man eben für jede identifizierte und erdenkliche Gefahr für eine solche Veranstaltung.
Erklären wie man das ein Held heraus auch z.b. in fluchtwegkonzept
anbringen ja das gibt's dann auch Bundesamt bundeslandspezifische Unterschiede was wir dann auch z.b. festgestellt haben in Leipzig mit dem Kongress gab's daneben andere
regulatorische Anforderungen an Fluchtwege als sie z.b. in Hamburg der Feier fahrenheit.
Und dann reichst Du eben als Veranstalter dieses Sicherheitskonzept ein.
Und dieses Sicherheitskonzept der holt sich jetzt dann die die die genehmigende Behörde,
das ist in dem Fall das Ordnungsamt den Rat der Experten und Experten ja sowas ist ein Brandschutzkonzept angeht das wird dann da guck guck dann hat die Feuerwehr drauf und so weiter und in diesem Fall das Sicherheitskonzept eben,
die Polizei und wenn die Polizei jetzt sagt dieses Sicherheitskonzept ist nicht ausreichen und das dem Ordnungsamt meldet.
Dann muss das kann das Ordnungsamt natürlich sich über die Einschätzung der Polizei hinwegsetzen.
Oder was hatte ich der viel wahrscheinlicher der Fall ist sie sagt okay wenn diese wenn hier offenbar von unseren.
Sicherheitsexperten Zweifel am Sicherheitskonzept existieren dann genehmigen wir die Veranstaltung nicht und genau diesen Hebel,
nutzt jetzt der Polizeipräsident Nils Hoffmann Ritterbusch und macht die Zustimmung zum Sicherheitskonzept.
Von seiner Forderung abhängig das also eine Polizeiwache auf dem Gelände ist.
Und dass das Gelände bestraft werden kann von zivil und.
Uniformierten Beamtinnen und Beamten und sagt einfach ich kann mir einfach nicht vorstellen dass diese Veranstaltung sicher ist wenn meine.
Leute dort nicht rumlaufen natürlich muss er noch mehr finden.
Um quasi seine Zustimmung zum Sicherheitskonzept zu verweigern oder das Sicherheitskonzept zu kritisieren und da hat er sich jetzt sehr viel Mühe gegeben hat dann also das vom Kulturkosmos vorgelegte Sicherheitskonzept.
Sehr genau geprüft und dann natürlich auch entsprechende Haare in der Suppe gefunden einige davon sind.
Gleich mal verargumentiert war andere weniger nun ist es auch so dass du z.b. nicht unbedingt,
alle die Anforderungen der Versammlungsstättenverordnung so genau beschrieben sind das dann noch nicht das da nicht auch noch Spielraum für Diskussion wäre ja z.b. stellt sich dadurch aus die Frage,
in welchem Risikobereich man diese Veranstaltung sieht stuft man die ein wie sage ich mal ein Hochrisikospiel der der zweiten Liga.
Zwischen was weiß ich dem dem dem HSV und dem FC St Pauli.
Wo man weiß da gibt's Rivalitäten oder stuft man die 1 als was weiß ich ein Freundschaftsspiel zwischen zwei Regionalliga Verein wo es eine Bratwurst gibt und ein Bier ne oder wird dann ebenso,
da gibt's natürlich Spielraum für,
Einschätzung und jetzt diesen Spielraum der geht jetzt daneben von dem Polizeipräsidenten ausgenutzt der daneben sagt diese Veranstaltung ist.
Unsicher und wir können diesen Sicherheitskonzept nicht zustimmen weil die verantwortbar die Veranstalter unverantwortlich mit allerlei Gefahren.
Umgehen und das ist das was wenn ich mich jetzt nicht täusche vor anderthalb Wochen oder vor zwei Wochen.
Ungefähr von der Polizei dann auch an die Öffentlichkeit lanciert wurde mit dem Hinweis das Festival kann ich könnte so nicht stattfinden.
Wasser durch eine riesige Gefahr dann auch für das Festival also euch ist ist wenn du mich einmal.
Das Gerücht kursiert das kann nicht stattfinden oder findet nicht statt dann werden dir natürlich auch deine gesamten Vertragspartner nervös die Bus,
Buslinien Anbieter oder die die Reisebus Anbieter die gebucht sind für die Fahrten zum Veranstaltungsgelände ne deine Zulieferer für Sanitär und mit wem erfährt tausende Verträge mit allen möglichen Dienstleistern und Zulieferern.
Die dir danach die dann natürlich nervös werden und so findet jetzt also dieser Angriff auf dieses Festival statt nun ist meine persönliche Einschätzung.
Und das denke ich diese Einschätzung ist gestützt durch 22 Jahre die dieses Festival stattfindet dass die Sicherheit dort sehr ernst genommen wird.
Und das sieht das Sicherheitskonzept wie es dort jedes Jahr verbessert und verfeinert wird und auch angepasst wird neuen Anforderungen.
In dieser Form erprobt ist und es überhaupt keinen Anlass dazu gibt hier mit einer massiven Polizeipräsenz.
Rein zu.
Allein schon das muss man fällt auch noch mal ein wenig meine dass das difusion ein
politisch linken Einschlag hat ist ja sicherlich kein Geheimnis ist nicht im eigentlichen Sinne eine politische Veranstaltung aber das ganze so im tiefsten Mecklenburg-Vorpommern durchzuführen da sind sich natürlich auch alle Beteiligten,
schon allein darüber klar dass man die Sicherheit der Teilnehmer allein schon deshalb sicherstellen und muss weil man sich eben potentiellen am Umfeld bewegt
was vielleicht den eigentlichen eigenen politischen Überzeugung nicht unbedingt immer so konform läuft.
Die Veranstaltung findet statt unter dem Motto 4 Tage ferienkommunismus ne also das ist schon und i
natürlich sind am viele der dort Mitwirkenden Gruppen einen politischen Anspruch und einen rechten oder rechtsradikalen politischen antworten wirst du unter diesen nicht finden.
Tja und jetzt geht der jetzt geht der Streit los in der Polizei Mecklenburg-Vorpommern wann endet 2018 236 Stellen nicht besetzt.
Die häufen jährlich zwischen 150.000 acht 180.000 Überstunden an
die ländlichen Regionen sind weit und breit unterversorgt ja wenn da wenn du in wenn du heute in Lärz oder in Mirow in dem angrenzenden Dorf die Polizei rufst,
viel Erfolg.
Und ausgerechnet dieses Festival was nie irgendjemanden Ärger gemacht hat soll da jetzt einen Großeinsatz notwendig meinen Polizei hat echt Mühe gehabt.
Irgendwelche Anlässe zu Finn.
Der größere Teil der von der Polizei vorgetragenen angeblichen Straftaten wurde also hat sich nicht erhärtet wurden auch echt.
Schmutzige Vorwürfe hervorgehoben die die Polizei dann bei ihrer Pressekonferenz selber wieder entkräften durfte.
Und wir sehen so wie die Polizei dort agiert dass es hier eine,
also dass hier ein politischer Kampf stattfindet und dieser politische Kampf ist eigentlich der der wo sich die Frage stellt dürfen,
können wir heute 2019 selbstverwaltet Veranstaltung durchführen die sicher sind.
Mit 20 Jahren Erfahrung zeigen dass sie sicher bleiben wo jeder jedes jedes Bierfest einer Kleinstadt zu mehr verletzten mehr Strafanzeigen führt.
Und ist das in Ordnung oder können Sicherheit und Ordnung nur durch die Polizei hergestellt werden es ist jetzt so wir haben heute Mittwoch den 15. Mai.
Morgen am 16. Mai wird der Kulturkosmos eV ein erneut überarbeitetes Sicherheitskonzept vorlegen.
Haben einige Anforderungen gibt es da noch zu erfüllen sind dann also sowas wie die genaue
genau in Fluchtwege das ist natürlich,
tut mir leid so eine Anforderung weißt du wenn du auf einem riesigen auf einer riesigen Wiese bist ja wo in alle Richtung kilometerweit Platz ist kommt ein natürlich auf Anhieb die Forderung wann muss jetzt die signierte Fluchtwege
haben ein bisschen komisch vor es gab.
Die Forderung nach ich das war sehr schön also die Bezahlung bei der Fusion wäre unzureichend da dazu kann ich nur sagen.
Selbst die eine Beschwerde die Diskussion in 22 Jahren nicht hatte.
Bomann.
Mangelnde Beschallung.
Und dann gibt es echte gibt es seit gibt es seit einiger Zeit eben diese Anforderung für Sicherheitskräfte.
Einen sogenannten 34a Schein zu haben den müssen wir müssen gewerbliche Security-Mitarbeiter.
Haben dass es ihr Wissen ich glaube so eine IHK Prüfung oder so nichts Besonderes kann man haben ja kann man machen.
Das Problem ist den haben natürlich nur gewerbliche die sich sicherlich Bild wenn ich versichert Rede der g-minor die Sicherheit Security-Leute.
Und jetzt ist es so wenn du dich auf dem freien Markt der Security-Leute um schaust.
Dann ist das nicht so einfach.
Welche zu finden die über jeden Zweifel erhaben sind ja die.
Security Szene ist wie wir alle wissen
gerne mal in bestimmten anderen politischen oder rechtlichen Kontexten unterwegs es gibt da
irgend an einigen Stellen.
Skandale um Security Menschen in Unterkünften für geflüchtete wie erinnern uns an,
die Nähe zur der organisierten Kriminalität im im Rockermilieu ja es ist nicht so einfach dir Security-Leute zu organisieren weil es ist vor allem nicht so einfach dir die zu organisieren die da nicht mit,
Neckar geschoren mit Bomberjacke ankommen und.
Ein Arbeitsalltag gewöhnt sind der wo jeder Tag ein ein Kampf um Leben und Tod ist und die froh sind wenn sie dann abends von der Schicht zurückkommen sondern eben ich sag mal im weitesten Sinne,
Berliner Hamburger Technoszene kompatibel sind wo du eben.
Einfachen vernünftigen Umgang der Leute untereinander und das auch ziemlich genau würde ich ernsthaft sagen die große und größte Befürchtung.
Die der Kulturkosmos gegenüber diesen Vorstoß der Polizei hat das nämlich das existierende Sicherheitskonzept jetzt auf den Kopf gestellt wird das.
Eigenverantwortung und Rücksichtnahme sind eine Kultur Frage die die sich,
gar nicht so genau beantworten lässt ich kenne die Frage ja auch regelmäßig wenn ich
Presse Betreuer beim Camp oder beim Kongress wo die Leute sagen Mensch ich habe irgendwie gedacht hier
City bin ich nur mit von irgendwelchen Macker Sexisten umgeben die aus der Hacker Szene kommen und blöde Sprüche reißen aber alle gehen hier irgendwie ordentlich miteinander um
woher wie kriegt ihr das hin und dass das Spannende ist.
Dass man das hinkriegt weil es so ist und nicht weil man das erzwingen kann und Sicherheitskonzepte die durch die Polizei geregelt.
Die haben immer ganz andere Ansprache die haben die haben da Ansprache der das anweisen die haben Ansprache tu was ich dir sage oder ja und das ist natürlich ein ganz anderes Konzept.
Als das was hier auf den Kulturkosmos Veranstaltung auf den CCC Veranstaltungen gepflegt wird paradoxerweise.
Sie das aber die Veranstaltung wo du weniger Ärger hast jeder zu klassische Lehre würde eigentlich sagen wenn die Polizei weg ist.
Dann tanzen die Katzen auf dem Tisch oder die Mäuse auf dem Tisch und es bricht Sodom und Gomorrha aus.
Und für viele Veranstaltung ist das auch der Fall es gibt andererseits Veranstaltung wie beispielsweise Demonstrationen.
Im weitesten Sinne humoristisch geprägter linker Vereinigungen.
Wo du fährst jetzt je mehr Polizisten da sind desto mehr Ärger entsteht.
Klassische Lehre die die Polizei z.b. in Berlin-Kreuzberg in den letzten 10 Jahren,
langsam zieht dass sie sehen ach schau an jedem weniger Polizisten wir sichtbar beim ersten Mal einsetzten.
Desto weniger Krawall haben wir.
Völlig paradox ne weil man denkt ja eigentlich Polizei ist da um den Krawall zu verhindern stellt sich aber raus einfach durch das martialische auftreten durch die Atmosphäre die durch diese Polizeipräsident Präsenz entsteht.
Ändert sich die Kultur der Veranstaltung ändert sich die Kultur und die Atmosphäre die dort die dort stattfindet ist kommt zu Krawall jetzt hat er durch die Polizei er Moment unsere Präsenz kann ja jetzt nicht hier die Entschuldigung sein das Krawall ausbricht
ja und wenn die wenn die was gegen uns haben sind das schlechte Menschen.
Ich kann diese Position natürlich auch weitesten im weitesten Sinne nachvollziehen aber wenn das Ziel wäre dass die Veranstaltung sicher durchgeführt wird.
Dann würde sich die Polizei natürlich auch auf den Kompromissvorschlag des Kulturkosmos einlassen der nämlich sagt pass auf ihr baut eine Polizeiwache direkt.
Am Festivalgelände am Festivalgelände außerhalb.
Türen und Tore da wo er sich auch da der ZOB befindet der zentrale Omnibusbahnhof und übrigens auch finde ich ihn sehr schönen Vergleich.
Der Geldautomat den brauchen die Leute auch aber der muss ja nun wirklich nicht auf der Tanzfläche stehen und deswegen steht der.
Deswegen steht er dort ja an zentraler Stelle gut erreichbar gut ausgeschildert ne wir möchten genauso wie wir möchten das
die Menschen zu Geldautomaten gehen wenn sie Geld brauchen um uns das zu geben möchten wir dass die Leute die Polizei erreichen können wenn Sie die braunes der steht wohl außer Frage.
Ob wir 1100 Polizisten auf dem Festivalgelände brauchen.
Die dort 24 Stunden Schichten schieben und du über das Gelände latschen.
Und dann natürlich auch Polizeiarbeit passt sich ja auch immer dem dem Level der Herausforderung an ja das finde ich kann man sehr schön sehen wenn du sagen wir mal in Berlin.
Nachts besoffen ohne Licht freihändig über eine rote Ampel fährt mit dem Fahrrad und dabei ein Polizeiauto überholt und Mittelfinger zeigst ja dann überholt dich das Polizeiauto die Kurbel das Fenster runter und sagen sag mal bist du bescheuert.
Mach gefälligst Licht an und fahren weiter wenn du in einer wohlbehütet eine Kleinstadt ein Bonbon Papier achtlos auf den Boden wirst in einer schönen Reihenhaussiedlung.
Da musst du damit rechnen niedergeknüppelt zu werden,
und endlich endlich kannst du dir natürlich jetzt vorstellen wenn auf einmal 1100 Polizisten auf dem Fusion Festival Gelände sind und sagen ja okay irgendwas müssen wir jetzt hier machen,
die werden natürlich dann auch ihre Schwelle um was sie sich kümmern anpassen und daneben was weiß ich mal ne.
Mal Menschen kontrollieren die vielleicht gerade gar nicht kontrolliert werden wollen und da entstehen dann Dynamiken vor denen muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
Da sag ich jetzt meine persönliche Meinung ich tatsächlich Sorge habe denn.
Was ich fürchte was passieren könnte wenn die Polizei nun mit 1100 Polizisten in diesem Festival rumrennt dann ist es doch nur eine Frage der Zeit bis es da zu irgendwelchen Zusammenstößen kommt
und wenn die Polizei dann versucht sich irgendjemanden zugreifen oder den irgendwie belästigt oder der sich nicht ne,
dann hast du ruckzuck Menschen drumherum die ihren Festival Teilnehmer oder ihre Teilnehmerinnen in irgendeiner Form stürzen möchte,
und schon hast du Polizisten sagen wir brauchen jetzt hier Verstärkung und plötzlich hast du dann dort genau die Massen,
Schlägereien Auseinandersetzungen Verhaftung Konflikte von denen mit großer.
Mit dem großen Planung mit großer Sorgfalt mit einem funktionierenden Sicherheitskonzept diese Veranstaltung 22 Jahre lang,
frei gehalten wurde und das ist der die kulturelle Auseinandersetzung Bierstadt.
Hilfe dazu noch sagen ist alles richtig.
Das so eine Konfrontation noch nicht mal der Default wäre oder Schule also ich würde er damit rechnen das sollte jetzt sozusagen das durchgesetzt werden und,
machen wir Sex vor Diffusion ist nicht absagt also wenn diese Veranstaltung abgesagt wird.
Die wird nicht abgesagt wievielten wird dieses Jahr statt.
Genau da die muss stattfinden sonst wäre.
Schalte und würde dann die gelbe ist wahrscheinlich auch gar keine Schule mehr ne das heißt wie auch immer das Ganze ausgeht unter den Bedingungen wird sie stattfinden sollte sich,
die Polizei hier durchsetzen und hat sich so eine Präsenz machen dann wäre selbstverständlich also
nicht dass ich kenn jetzt keine Pläne ich habe da keinerlei einzigsten in Rheine Einschätzung der Veranstaltung ist als jene die ich doch ganz gut zu kennen glaube es wäre zunächst einmal eine kreative Antwort zu erwarten
ja
Damit wäre zu rechnen.
Ja also ich sehe da clownsarmee hin durch die Gegend ziehen und geht kann mir einfach nicht vorstellen.
Bitte nicht die Leute auf falsche Gedanken.
Ja also.
Katastrophal wenn die Polizei da nicht ernst genommen würde auf.
Ja das ist ja nur ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass sie bezahlen Ihre ihr geschrieben ihre ihre Vorgehensweise unbegleitet vornehmen würden so oder so also aber.
Irgendwann erreicht das halt auch sein. Wenn das ganze mit weiterer Repressionen beantwortet wird und man irgendwie hier auch so ein bisschen davon ausgehen muss hier wird eine Maßnahme eingeleitet für die es einfach keinen
Grund gibt es diese ist das richtig sehe hat dieser Polizeipräsident ja mittlerweile auch zugeben müssen dass er selber noch nicht auf dieser Veranstaltung war.
Was ist etwas esse mit dem Hubschrauber drüber geflogen.
Wurde dir auch richtig auftragen soll ja geil du hast YouTube-Videos geguckt und bist mit dem Hubschrauber geflogen was hat denn der Hubschraubereinsatz gekostet Warum klingelst du nicht einfach mal an der Tür
und lässt dir mal dass das Gelände zeigen ja also es wird es wird es wenn hier tatsächlich also von Seiten der Polizei sind hier.
Auf unklare.
Nicht nachvollziehbare Weise Fronten verhärtet worden direkt so eine also Angriff auf die Veranstalter klare Kante zeigen wir sehen natürlich jetzt dass der Polizeipräsident schon sein bisschen,
zurückrudern muss und sich auf die.
Auf die Forderungen versteift dachte natürlich dort die Polizei,
Zugang zum Gelände haben muss was sie übrigens immer hatte er stand nie außer Frage,
die Polizei anlassbezogen jederzeit Zugang zum Gelände bekommt nur eben nicht mit 1100 Polizisten
in Zivil und in Uniform um dort eine eigene Wache zu errichten als er schon eine eine kleine Dimension unter,
ich finde auch natürlich ist davon auszugehen dass es hier sollte die Polizei diesen Anspruch,
feste durchsetzen und daran festhalten ist natürlich damit zu rechnen dass es hier zu einem.
Kreativen zu einer kreativen Prozessbegleitung kommen könnte
ja auf jeden Fall ist das sehr viel wahrscheinlicher als dass es hier zu irgendwelchen gewaltsamen Protesten kommen würde das halte ich für sehr wenig wahrscheinlich gleichzeitig kenne ich aber auch.
Wenn ich mich auf Heiligendamm ZBB erinnere G8 Gipfel 2007.
Nils Hoffmann Ritterbusch ist der auch in Erinnerung übrigens.
Erinnere da waren diese Clowns Armeen sehr viel im Einsatz Nase die Blende ich weiß nicht genau wie die Abkürzung ist ca klandestin sowieso international Clowns army.
Die.
Na in uniformiert irgendwie dann die die Polizisten begleiten ne weißt du wer am Ende als erstes auf die Fresse bekommen hat von denen,
natürlich die weil die Polizisten sich nach mehreren Tagen auch gesagt haben jetzt reiten wir reich ziemlich hier verarschen zu lassen und wenn ich die wenn ich wenn die Gewalttäter,
die hier eigentlich fangen möchte so schnell wegrennen dann haue ich halt den Clown auf die Fresse.
Und das ist leider bitter leider leider Gottes da natürlich passiert dann werden als nächstes so Gerüchte gestreut wie,
in den Wasserpistolen der Clowns sei kein Wasser sondern wahlweise Salpetersäure Salzsäure oder u.
Ja und ruckzuck.
Kriegen die Clowns dann halt auf die Nase weil sie die Polizisten mit Wasser bespritzen ruckzuck haben die irgendein Polizisten mal ins Gesicht gespritzt mit ihrer 1 € Wasserpistole und daraus wird eine schwere Körperverletzung im Amt ja.
Und genau diese Konflikte alle kannst du dir sparen indem du einfach sagst ok wir wir verzichten auf diese,
Konfrontation interessanterweise gibt es eigentlich nur eine politische Partei.
Die Denise Hoffmann Ritterbusch mit seinem Vorstoß Rückenwind gibt welche Partei das ist kann man sich natürlich vorstellen.
Das ist die Alternative für deutsche Deppen die dann sagt es handelt sich um eine Scheindebatte die Juden kein aber kein rechtsfreier Raum sauer sein keine Toleranz für,
für linksradikale Leute.
Wann ist denn schon erstaunt da muss ich sagen da ich ja mit der mit der Öffentlichkeitsarbeit hier betraut bin lese ich ja die so wahrscheinlich jeden Artikel dazu den zumindest.
Zu kommen weil es schon erstaunt mit welcher erstens breite diese Veranstaltung hier angegriffen wird.
20 Jahre ohne nennenswerte Vorkommnisse soll nicht also wird sicherlich die ein oder andere.
Person geben der auf der Fusion die auf der Fusion Ziel und Opfer einer Straftat wurde gemessen.
An den 70.000 Menschen die sich dort versammeln ist das aber ein seltenes Ereignis und die Frage ist,
rechtfertigt dieses Ereignis eben eine derart massiver Polizeipräsenz,
bitte auf Fragen müssen das ist ja nicht kostenlos ne wenn du dir überlegst was die was die Polizisten da kosten was die Unterkunft für die kostet was es kostet die zu bekochen was die an Zulagen kriegen für Wochenendeinsatz und
Einsatz fern der Heimat reden wir hier ganz ganz schnell von einem siebenstelligen Betrag den.
Die Steuerzahler rin daneben leisten muss was mich ebenso begeistert oder überrascht ist die Unterstützung
die der Kulturkosmos hier bekommt und zwar nicht nur von den üblichen verdächtigen es gibt eine Petition auf Kulturkosmos de,
Schrägstrich mitmachen ich schaue jetzt mal ganz schnell die haben inzwischen.
Das ist der aktuelle Zähler zählt Popo 126.000 Menschen gezeichnet es gab.
In Lärz am Sonntag eine Demonstration der Anwohnerinnen und Anwohner an der örtlichen Kirche.
Das Nachbardorf Miro hat einen Bürgermeister mit Namen Henry Tesch von der CDU.
Der auf der Pressekonferenz ist Kulturkosmos sich sehr sehr für das Festival eingesetzt hat das müssen wir mal einspielen das ist nämlich echt krass was der gesagt.
Ja also ich meine hier will ja ganz deutlich wie.
Wenig Diffusion als Problem gesehen wird ja also das ist das ist hier aber eine Einigung
geben muss aber muss auch dazu sagen die Führerschein ist auch eine Veranstaltung die schon sehr drauf achtet mit den ganzen Nachbargemeinden ein gutes Auskommen zu haben.
Wäre das nicht so hättest du schon immer Protest gegeben in meiner wird irgendwie eine Woche lang mit den Leuten da die Hütte zugewuchert ja der Gedanke dass man diese besser abschirmen
könnte er,
kann man aber von der Hand weisen das heißt 24/7 ist da einfach alarm aber alle sind dafür weil die halt einfach einerseits verstanden haben was das kulturell bedeutet
ja aber ist natürlich auch ein wirtschaftlicher Faktor
kannst jetzt nicht so meißeln aufziehen weiß ob du da noch mal Einblicke hast wo überall die Gemeinden mit eingebunden werden aber von Essensversorgung und so weiter
dienstleistungsfinder Regel so dass sie erheblich davon profitieren und das eben auch nicht nur während der Fusion sondern eben übers ganze Jahr.
Ich werde das aber also ich weiß nicht ob wir erwähnt haben dass der Henry Tesch von der CDU ist.
Hast du schon gesagt ja ja.
Der klingt ein bisschen der klingt jetzt gar nicht so CDU typisch in in in seiner Äußerung aber er hat natürlich einen also der wirtschaftliche Faktor spielt
sicherlich auch eine Rolle wenn da die örtlichen Supermärkte leer gekauft werden und der
die kleine Fischbude in Mirow ein Fisch nach dem anderen verkauft das ist alles natürlich auch gerne gesehen aber was man glaube ich auch wirklich nicht vergessen darf ist.
Das sind sehr schwach besiedelte Regionen in denen es relativ wenig gibt
ja die haben ja in in Mirow
die diese besondere Situation der dass dass das europaweit angesehene Theaterfestival vor der Tür zu haben die haben besondere Situation dieses Kulturtechnik und Uhr und Techno Festival Fusion vor der Tür zu haben meinst du wie stolz die darauf sind.
Wenn ich nur das ist auch für den Tourismus ist das natürlich auch in unheimlicher Faktoren.
Aber ich sage dir gerade ich denke nicht dass das für das die nur aus kulturellen aus wirtschaftlichen Erwägungen sagen das ist toll das möchte ich bei mir zu Hause haben,
ja sondern die sind ist doch also es ist doch auch schön etwas etwas Besonderes bei sich zu haben und nur wirtschaftliche Erwägungen bringen nicht die Anwohner am Sonntag zur zu Demo vor die vor die vor die Kirche
ja die haben auch die haben auch eine Verbundenheit und eine Freude daran und auch das wird da,
soll da jetzt angegriffene zerstört werden okay wir haben glaube ich das Thema aber jetzt auch ausreichend lange behandelt.
Notar.
Ich will noch kurz sagen was jetzt passieren wird morgen wird der.
Kulturkosmos sein überarbeitetes Sicherheitskonzept einreichen es wird sich dann zeigen.
Ob der Polizeipräsident Nils Hoffmann Ritterbusch sag ok dieses Sicherheitskonzept überzeugt mich nun so dass ich entgegen meiner mehrfachen Ankündigung nun doch.
Dem Sicherheitskonzept zustimmen kann ohne zu verlangen dass wir eine Wache,
auf dem Polizeigelände auf dem Festivalgelände bekommen.
Würde das der Fall sein wird die Veranstaltung genehmigt die Polizei würde im Zweifelsfall wie schon lange vom Kulturkosmos vorgeschlagen.
An der Grenze zum Festivalgelände ihre Wache errichten können und wie immer anlassbezogen Zugang zum Festivalgelände bekommen wenn.
Hoffmann Ritterbusch auf der Position bleibt auf der sich im Prinzip seit November letzten Jahres verhärtet hat dass er den Sicherheitskonzept einfach solange nicht zustimmen wird bis er diese Auflagen durch gepresst hat.
Dann wird es eventuell.
Zu einem oder wird es zu einer gerichtlichen Auseinandersetzung kommen und dann wird dieser Fall von Gerichten geklärt werden Dir Kulturkosmos vertritt die Rechtsauffassung das.
Die Polizei hier keinen keine Rechtsgrundlage hat ein eine,
einen ungehinderten Zugang zum Gelände zu verlangen und eine Polizeiwache dort zu errichten,
die beziehen sich da allerdings auch so ein Gummiparagraph in das ist der Paragraph zur Gefahrenabwehr der nämlich in ungefähr jeden Polizeigesetz natürlich sagt die Polizei darf überall rein zur Gefahrenabwehr ist ja auch sinnvoll ja wenn ihr vor eine Gefahr besteht.
Darf die Polizei da rein das heißt man wird sich darüber streiten müssen ob hier eine Gefahr.
Besteht und ob Gefahrenabwehr ein rein rein präventiv zu verstehen ist also Gummiparagraph Polizei darf überall rein weil es könnt ihr eine Gefahr.
Entstehen.
Oder man sagt wenn es Anhaltspunkte für eine Gefahr gibt dann ist es sinnvoll gibt dass die Polizei da rein kommt da wird also dann so sofern sich der Herr Hoffmann Ritterbusch weiter.
Gegen jede Kompromiss Vorschläge sperrt
dann ein Gerichtsverfahren herbeiführen herbeigeführt werden und dieses Gerichtsverfahren wird ein Urteil haben diesem Urteil das sieht natürlich dann entsprechend verbindlich sein für alle Beteiligten
sollte das Urteil nun lauten diese Veranstaltung ist sicher genug wenn die Polizei draußen vor der Tür steht und jederzeit einsatzbereit ist dann wäre das der Fall sollte das Urteil lauten.
Nein der Kulturkosmos muss die Auflage der Polizei akzeptieren dann gäbe es eben eine Fusion,
mit Polizeiwache und Bestrafung des Geländes nach Gerichtsbeschluss früher wird der Kulturkosmos so etwas sicherlich nicht akzeptieren und.
Dann im Zweifelsfall je nachdem wie das läuft wenn sich dann herausstellen sollte dass die.
Polizei auch in den kommenden Jahren an dieser Forderung festhält und von dieser,
denke ich wirtschaftlich kaum zu vertretenden und auch politisch kaum zu vertreten in Maßnahme nicht ab rückt.
Dann wäre das tatsächlich das Ende des Fusion fest um nichts Geringeres.
Geht es hier dann zumindest für 2020 deswegen begleiten wir das hier übrigens nicht nur,
sondern auch die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte hat sich zu diesem Thema geäußert und in einem sehr seltenen,
würde ich sagen Feature der Republica waren dann Eule vom Kulturkosmos und ich noch in der Lage der Nation wo er der Vorsitzende der,
Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte einer der Podcast Gastgeber ist ich weiß nicht ob die das inzwischen veröffentlicht.
Nein also auf YouTube findest du den Mitschnitt von der Republica da kann man sich das anschauen bei der Lage der Nation ist das im hinter der Paywall für besondere vorderer verschwunden leider.
Theresa ist gut.
Hat er dich so ein dringendes Thema.
Müssen müssen ja alle selber wissen auf YouTube gibt's das also offenbar dann finden wir den dann haben wir den YouTube Link in den Hautarzt die sendung eigentlich ganz interessant da war auch Leonardo Busch.
Abend und verschiedene weitere interessante Themen zu Gastes deswegen fänd ich das schade das hier,
der Öffentlichkeit fernzuhalten aber ist ja schön dass es wie dieses auf der YouTube Plattform den den Mitschnitt zu sehen gibt.
Bei der Gelegenheit übrigens ebenfalls auf YouTube gibt's einen.
Vortrag von mir bei der timcon ich bin ja jung und dynamisch und cool deswegen nicht auf der alte Säcke Veranstaltungen Republik hat dieses Jahr aufgetreten sondern auf der,
was heißt teenage internetworking Konferenz also der der Jugendlichen sub Konferenz der Republica.
Euch einen Vortrag gehalten mit dem Titel muss ich mal kurz gucken wie Hacker hacken und mich hoffentlich nicht.
Der sei bei dieser Gelegenheit auch noch kurz erwähnt hast du ihr was bei der Republica gemacht.
Ich habe kurz auf dem Hof rumgestanden am Montag aber nur den einen Nachmittag da und dann war ja auch wieder weg ich muss sagen nicht erreicht die Republikaner nur noch begrenzt.
Ja kann man da reden wir dann bei der Republik hat 20 Uhr noch mal drüber wie das ist weil wir haben noch viele andere Themen oder wollen wir noch was zu Republica sagen.
Ich kann nicht soviel zur Republica
sagen also wissen habe es auch noch nicht viel tox nachgeschaut es wäre ich sicherlich mit dem einen oder anderen noch mal machen aber ich fühl mich jetzt nicht qualifiziert über die Veranstaltung deine Aussage zutreffen dich.
Begleite das mit Interesse bin ich unbedingt mit allem mit so
glücklich wie sich das entwickelt sehe aber dass sie ihre Agenda da einig sehr erfolgreich vertreten und verfolgen immer einer der Bundespräsident die Veranstaltungen
eröffnet und ja er hat sogar von Podcast gesprochen die toll das doch ist also sie.
Dann macht er jetzt auch ein.
Ja ist.
Hat er schon concept instrumental.
Nee ist einfach besser der mal den Forschergeist gehört hat er neulich sundo lobend erwähnt hat einen anderen Rede seitdem dreht bei ihm einfach durch irgendwie jetzt hört er nur noch Podcast,
so ist das halt bei der Bundespräsident mal gucken wann er hier auch nur einschaltet Hallo Frank-Walter.
Herzlich willkommen auf unserem Kanal.
Gut dann wollen wir mal wollen wir mal die die Themen behandeln der Woche ich werde mich jetzt bemühen die etwas schneller zu.
Es geht los mit der Schwachstelle in aller Munde die WhatsApp weil durability
die jetzt hier irgendwie Probleme macht übrigens da fand ich es sehr schön wie darüber berichtet wurde oder wie zumindest die die die Headlines sich dazulassen ja ich hörte davon morgens im Deutschlandradio.
In den Nachrichten ja es gibt eine krasse Schwachstelle bei bei Whatsapp oder müssen jetzt alle irgendwie loswerden,
spannend fand ich aber dann tatsächlich so die die Titel die Überschriften die so Dich online zu dem Thema gefunden habe.
Darunter WhatsApp gehackt bitte Update installieren.
Würdest du denkst okay interessant das andere war Lücke
hacker nutzen Lücke bei Whatsapp für auch witzig also Lücke ist natürlich ein großes Wort für remote code execution die von einem.
Staatstrojaner Hersteller genutzt wird um Geräte zu infizieren deswegen möchte ich das kurz noch mal in den Kontext einordnen den wir nämlich hierbei LocoNet fertig schon lange verfolgen also.
Die NSA Group ist ein israelisches Unternehmen das
Staatstrojaner SS Service herstellt die also quasi die Infrastruktur für Staatstrojaner herstellt inklu und diese dann
anbietet an Staaten der und so lupenreine Demokrat Uhren wie die Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate,
Mexiko zu ihren Kunden zählen.
In Mexiko wurde diese Chartsoftware dann gegen einen Journalisten eingesetzt
in den Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten gegen Ahmed Mansour außerdem haben wir entscheidende Hinweise darauf dass sie in Saudi Arabien gegen Jamal khashoggi eingesetzt wurde auch da darüber hatten wir hier
berichtet und es gab dann vor einigen Monaten diesen Bericht über die Gruppe die das quasi die für die Saudis da arbeitet Vogel ehemalige NSA Hacker
jetzt eben im privaten Sektor für die Saudis arbeiten.
Und da wurde berichtet sie brauchten immer nur die Telefonnummer eines Zieles einer zieht Person um diese zu hacken das war aber nicht klar wie das denn passieren sollte nun stellt sich heraus dass es eben einen.
In der WhatsApp App einen Buffer Overflow bei eingehenden Anrufen gab wenn ich das richtig verstehe sogar gleichermaßen in der Android-Version als auch in der iOS Version.
Und dieser Buffer Overflow hat eben quasi dazu geführt dass du du schickst quasi ein spezifisches.
Unspezifische manipulierten Anrufversuch an,
das Gerät und nur durch die nur in dem Teil der App der diese Interaktion macht er mir zu sagen ok hier ist dieser Anruf ich verstehe jetzt welche Art
der hat und wie ich den weiterverarbeiten muss ich lasse jetzt das Telefon klingeln und stelle dann die Verbindung her ja was für eine relativ geringer Teil der Codebasis ist und vor allem einen Teil den du auslösen und angreifen kannst
ohne dass eine Interaktion stattfindet also es ist nicht so etwas wie du musst eine Nachricht schicken diese muss angezeigt werden oder die Nachricht.
Muss eine Audiodatei sein und und oder ein Video bestimmter Form und danach stürzt das Handy ab oder so sondern einfach nur ein Anruf der offenbar unbeantwortet bleibt.
Reicht aus wenn der spezifisch manipuliert ist um das Gerät auf dem Gerät eine einen arbiträren,
Programmcode auszuführen dahinter müssen dann aber immer noch weitere Schwachstellen sein von iOS z.b. diesen Prozess der dann da irgendwie offenbar,
ausgestoßen angestoßen werden kann der findet nämlich auch in aos dann in einer Sandbox Stadt also separiert von dem Rest des Betriebssystems und den anderen Apps und offenbaren sie dann da auch noch weitere Schwachstellen hinter ge
Saint die daneben eine dauerhafte Infektion des iOS Gerätes mit Malware ermöglicht haben,
das ist so ungefähr die Art Schwachstelle oder die Art Schwachstellen Kombination vor der sich alle für.
Und hier eben eingesetzt von dieser Staat oder dieser.
Privaten hacking Firma die ihren Dienst in die ihre Fähigkeiten in den Dienst von Unternehmen stellt,
einige habe ich von starten stellt einige habe ich genannt weitere verdächtigte Staaten sind Israel selber Türkei Thailand Katar Kenia Usbekistan Mosambik Marokko Jemen Ungarn
Saudi-Arabien hatte ich genannt in Nigeria und Bachrain also wir sehen nur die feinsten aller Demokratien.
Setzen diese Software ein wir können also jetzt erstmal uns freuen dass diese Schwachstelle entdeckt wurde übrigens von Whatsapp selber,
gefixt wurde nun mit einem Update und dieses zu installieren ist nicht optional solange ihr euch nicht dazu entscheidet das einzig wahre und richtige zu tun und WhatsApp sowieso zu denen dann.
Ja wobei die Release Notes sind ganz hübsch also die neue diese gefixte Version wird hier.
Das neue emoji ist oder Sonne.
Ja du kannst dicker jetzt in der Originalgröße sehen wenn du eine Benachrichtigung gedrückt hältst dass die vollständige Erläuterung dieses Updates.
Also eine assist
dass das wird würde ich als eine strategische Entscheidungen werden die haben jetzt zweifelsfrei dieses Update irgendwie bereitgestellt haben das schon mal da wo die apt Auto Update durchmarschieren,
schon mal ihre größten größeren Teil ihrer Nutzerbasis einfach so abgefackelt und sind dann an die Öffentlichkeit gegangen würde mich jetzt nicht wundern wenn sie dazu tun übrigens ich vermute
hier nur einen Zusammenhang aber aos hat heute auch in einen ab
bekommen in den eine eine und eine eine Reihe an haarsträubender Schwachstellen beseitigt für dich glaube ich wieso was t86 Stück an der Zahl also auch dieses Update sollte man.
Installiere es könnte natürlich sein das ist aber zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt unbekannt dass diese WhatsApp Vorschau
auch mehr gefunden haben als nur ihre eigene Schwachstelle.
Und unter Umständen eben auch noch mal was Hempels hatten oder attack traces dass sie die sie dann vielleicht Apple gegeben haben um um da eben auch noch mal vorstellen zu beseitigen die im weiteren Verlauf der Ausnutzung zum Einsatz.
Sieht mir auf jeden Fall wieder schön,
um so etwas auszunutzen ist es halt auch erforderlich eine ganze Kaskade von Sicherheitslücken aneinander zu hängen das ist schon ein organisatorischer Aufwand den wirklich nur die hochmotivierten und best finanziert Aston
Gruppen machen können also z.b. im so staatlichen motivierte Hackergruppen
bedeutet aber auch dass wenn vielleicht auch nur eine einzige dieser Sicherheitslücken frühzeitig irgendwo auch mal gemeldet werden würde und nicht in der Schublade verschwindet auf einmal solche Angriff cascaden auch nicht mehr funktionieren können,
klares Plädoyer an dieser Stelle wieder zurückzukehren oder überhaupt mal hinzugehen zu einer Politik,
Aufklärung und frühzeitigen Dokumentation von Sicherheitslücken anstatt sie für irgendwelche theoretischen zukünftigen Fälle wo man dann unter Umständen mal eine oder zwei Personen abhören kann,
das einfach nicht so harten sondern einfach offenzulegen.
Ja wir sehen auch also der das was immer passiert mit solchen Schwachsinn diese Schwachstelle betrifft eben uns alle er hat deswegen müssen auch wir alle jetzt unsere Gerät.
Weil wir alle diesem Risiko ausgesetzt waren weil offenbar Leute bei NSA gesagt haben ach geil die Schwachstelle nutzen wir verkaufen die an an irgendwelche Herrscher,
Stadt dafür zu sorgen dass das die Geräte sicher gemacht werden und die Samen dieser Markt ist halt einfach schon
leider sehr ekelhaft und wir alle sind darin einfach nur Spielbälle die dann ab und zu mal im Radio hören wir müssen mal wieder ein Update machen potenziell aber und natürlich auch immer dem Risiko ausgesetzt werden.
Das so was gegen uns eingesetzt wird und irgendwie mangelt es an den Geschichten
wo sie mal sagen wir haben das gegen jemanden von dem wirklich bösen eingesetzt sie hören irgendwie immer nur dass Journalisten damit ausspionieren und umbringen und dass sie,
das ist irgendwelche Staaten einsetzen wo man sicherlich weiß dass die das jetzt nicht irgendwie gegen Terroristen und kriminelle einsetzen bzw eine andere Definition von Terroristen und kriminelle haben als wir vielleicht in einem,
Rechtsstaat pflegen würden.
Du musst auf das Positive sehen immerhin gewälzt die Sticker auch in Originalgröße sehen wenn wir die Benachrichtigung gedrückt halten.
Das ist doch einfach nur damit die Leute das Update auf wirklich installieren und nicht einfach nur sagen war ich morgen.
Weiß der Geier ob das Feature gekommen wäre.
Wir müssen du musst auf dein kleines zuckerbrötchen noch dazu geben wenn du deine Hausaufgaben machst dann kriegst du auch größere Sticker.
Gott.
So dann haben wir eine weitere Schwachstelle über die es zu berichten gilt der CCC durfte endlich veröffentlichen.
Schwachstellen die einige unserer Mitglieder bei.
Abus gefunden haben aber sehr in deutscher Hersteller für so kennt man eigentlich für schlichte Schlösser oder sowas ne Schlösser Fahrradschloss.
Vor allem.
Die haben sich aber vor ich glaube so ungefähr 2011 haben die sich 2010 haben die sich entschieden.
Überwachungskameras mit IP auch anzubieten ihrem Feuer auch auch schon Überwachungskameras angeboten und dann ging es eben darum na ja wie wäre es denn mal mit Überwachungskameras die,
wie war das Internet arbeiten also irgendwie die Ihre Daten über IP versenden die vielleicht auch über IP quasi Pep zugreifbar sind solche Scherze also Netzwerk angebundene,
Überwachungskameras die der Hersteller Abos verkauft.
Jetzt stellte sich natürlich wie so häufig wenn Unternehmen in solche Entscheidung treffen heraus dass sie die Kompetenz gar nicht vor Ort selber haben dann immer wenn traditionelle Broschen,
Hey irgendwie was mit Internet machen dann machen sie es im Zweifelsfall zu spät und stellen fest wir haben 200 Jahre Tradition im Bau von,
von mir aus Überwachungskamera System und von mir aus auch Schlössern aber wir haben keine Expertise im Bau von Internet Geräten also kaufen und sie doch einfach.
Ein in diesem Fall.
Von einem Hersteller mit dem traditionsreichen und wohlklingenden Namen trainmedia mit Sitz in.
Taiwan wenn ich mich nicht täusche so jetzt kriegen diese Kameras wurden von 2010 bis 2014 vertrieben.
Und landen in den Händen von Elias Morath Alexander Karl und Martin Dessauer vom CCC in,
Düsseldorf dem chaosdorf und die schauen sich die an und finden direkt 5 Schwachstellen ja eine hoch kritisch der mich mit fixer Administrator Benutzerkennung,
kann man Befehle ausführen drei davon kritisch lese und Schreibzugriffe als root die alle auf wieder zu Befehlsausführung führen direkter,
direkte Ausführung von Benutzereingaben,
ein Buffer Overflow und dann auch noch einen unautorisierten Zugriff auf den Videostream kaputter kann eine Kamera nicht sein ne du kannst sie jetzt also,
als root umbauen du kannst den Videostream abgreifen ne schlechter kann deine Kamera nicht mehr aufgestellt sein.
Wir haben denn das gemacht was wir CCC eigentlich ich würde jetzt sagen mehrmals im Monat quasi wöchentlich machen Hersteller darüber in Kenntnis gesetzt gibt's dann eine schöne zusammenschrift der Schwachstellen mit Empfehlung zur Behebung.
Und haben das an Abus gesendet im November 2018.
Aber keine Antwort bekommen dann habe ich das ganze noch mal geschickt ich glaube im Januar oder Februar.
Oder kam eine ganz böse Antwort oh ja mein Gott wären das gesehen aber das ist irgendwie im im im November ist es untergegangen was machen wir denn jetzt und so weiter okay aber du da alles kein Problem alles was wir wollen ist schaut euch das bitte an bestätigt die Schwachstellen und,
erklärt uns wie er sie beseitigt denn in 90 Tagen die ab jetzt laufen wären wir die Öffentlichkeit darüber in Kenntnis setzen.
Name erstmal also war ein freundlicher Austausch aber alles in Ordnung mit dem,
dortigen Produktmanager und dann hört mir erstmal gar nichts zurück mal so ein bisschen verwundert ich sehe ist das jetzt wieder eingeschlafen oder so dann meldet er sich aber dann wieder und sagt er wollte mal mit uns sprechen ja oder sagt er.
Also folgendes ist der Sachverhalt sie haben alle diese Schwachstellen bestätigt gibt es keinen Grund zur Diskussion.
Muss ich auch mal einfach positiv anmerken du sehr selten hast wenn du Leuten Schwachstellen meldest dann üblicherweise fangen die als erstes an die zu leugnen dann fangen sie an die runter zu verhandeln dann fangen sie irgendwann an.
Nur noch auf dem Boden liegen zu liegen und zu strampeln bis ich dann irgendwann akzeptieren alle diese komischen Phasen der Trauer hat Abus hier übersprungen hat sofort gesagt ja diese Schwachstellen gibt es,
wie haben die alle bestätigt brauche mir nicht zu diskutieren das ist wirklich auch mal positiv zu erwähnen.
So jetzt kommt jetzt kommt aber das ist das Traurige an der Geschichte sagte ja Problem ist wir würden gerne einen Update bereitstellen für diese Kameras a.
Wir verfügen nicht mehr über das Bild environment um ein Software-Update für diese Kameras zu bauen
also du hast ja dann quasi ne die entsprechenden libraries Compiler die Pakete die das Format am Ende herstellen wie diese Kamera ein Update frisst und so und dass da das haben wir nicht mehr.
Und der Hersteller grain Media der hat inzwischen den Besitzer gewechselt und existiert quasi auch nicht mehr.
Abgesehen davon haben wir eh kein Prozess für automatisierte Updates wir könnten höchstens irgendwie so ein manuelles Update auf unsere Webseite stellen mit anderen Worten.
Wir sind nicht in der Lage diese Kameras zu updaten sondern alles was wir jetzt noch machen können ist die,
austauschen.
Bei seitlich bärenstarke Sache weil diese Geräte ne wenn die bis 2014 verkauft wurden sind teilweise eben noch nicht einmal fünf Jahre alt und ein dann doch sehr gut beleumundet ist deutsches Unternehmen hat nicht daran gedacht dass die Updates brauchen,
tja Ergebnis Abos hat dann gesagt okay wir werden folgendes tun wir bieten jetzt ein.
Kostengünstiges Austauschprogramm.
Haben das bedeutet man kann sich jetzt an seine Händler wenden dann kann die alte kann also quasi seine alten Kameras dort reklamieren bekommt neue Kameras.
Zu einem stark vergünstigten Preis da bin ich natürlich mal gespannt wie dieser stark vergünstigte Preis dann am Ende ausfällt.
So wie ich mir das habe erklären lassen liegt das nicht ausschließlich in der Hand von Abus sondern auch in der Hand der Händler,
wie viel des Preisnachlasses den Abus gewährt die Händler weitergeben.
Aber ist natürlich eine äußerst unschöne Situation weil diese Kameras eben wenn du die im Einsatz hast dann hast du nicht nur eine davon im Einsatz sondern die kauft für die halt vielleicht zur Überwachung eines Geländes in mm,
im Dutzend der Bündel als Schütt waren und sie sind teilweise eben auch in größere Überwachungssysteme eingebunden.
Wo du unter Umständen jetzt Wechselseitige Kompatibilitätsprobleme,
warum erzähle ich das naja einerseits um Kunden dieser Kamera Modelle
hier an dieser Stelle auch noch mal darauf aufmerksam zu machen also gekauft irgendwann zwischen 2010 und 2014 die Modelle fangen alle mit tvip an es gibt auf ccc.de und bei Abus
eine Liste der betroffenen Modelle das sind sehr viele weil die quasi teilweise,
die gleiche Firmware auf was weiß ich in der Kamera haben die sich bewegen kann eine die sich nicht bewegen kann eine die wasserdicht ist eine die A30 luftdicht ist und so weiter es gibt relativ viele Geräte die eben quasi sehr große,
technische Basisteil.
Und natürlich warum erzähle ich die Geschichte hier im Logbuch Netzpolitik weil wir als CCC immer wieder sagen wir hätten gerne eine,
Herstellerhaftung für den fahrlässig,
Software Schwachstellen denn wäre wenn es so etwas 2010 schon gegeben hätte hätte aber es ist sicherlich mehr,
Mühe gemacht eine Update Infrastruktur für seine Geräte zu haben für aktuelle Geräte wurde mir versprochen haben Sie so etwas wir sagen außerdem immer wieder wir hätten gerne.
Für die Hersteller verpflichtend die.
Die also die Quali für das Eindringen in den Markt verpflichten die Auflage das Update dafür bereitgestellt werden können und zwar für einen definierten Zeitraum,
da wir Stichwort Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum diskutieren wir das immer und natürlich haben wir auch immer gefordert dass wenn.
Der Nutzerinnen oder genutzt hat sich dafür entscheidet eine Open Source alternative Firmware auf dieses Gerät,
anzubringen dass das möglich ist denn was wir jetzt hier haben mit quasi ne vier oder fünf Jahres Volumina verkaufte Abus Kameras die alle jetzt nicht mehr sicher betrieben werden können,
es sei denn unter eben ganz hohen Netzwerk Sicherheitsauflagen und so weiter die du im Zweifelsfall bei den Kunden nicht findest,
ist ja auch jetzt alles müde ja die also nicht nur müssen dann neu gekauft werden zu günstigen Konditionen die alten müssen entsorgt werden ja obwohl die eigentlich natürlich problemlos funktionierende Kameras in die haben halt nur
potenziell eine ganze Reihe Zusatzfunktionen die man auf diesen Kameras in Zweifelsfall als Besitzer nicht haben möchte.
Insofern wäre es natürlich toll wenn ich hier jetzt die Möglichkeit bestünde mit.
Unabhängig gepflegten sicheren alternativ Firmware diese Geräte weiter zu betreiben also deshalb an dieser Stelle noch mal die Erinnerung.
Warum das politisch so eine wichtige Forderung ist und warum das jetzt hier zu Problemen führt,
und wir haben uns versichern lassen das Abus die notwendigen Lektionen schon viel früher gelernt hat insofern.
Kann ich hier tatsächlich die die Rolle von Abus auch ein bisschen mitfühlend sehen aber ich sagte natürlich immer noch viel größeres Mitgefühl für die Kundinnen und Kunden die den Kram mit zu Hause stehen haben und unnötigen.
Vermeidbaren Ärger nun mit ihren überwachungs ist.
Das ganze Zeug natürlich auch sehr schön wie was für einen Anpassungsdruck jetzt auf.
Nimm es mal als Beispiel deutsche Unternehmungen das betrifft natürlich nicht nur die deutschen aber ist ja normal der Kulturraum den wir hier besser verstehen und auch näher betrachten unternehmen wir Abus hat halt bisher Schlösser verkauft,
das heißt die hatten zum Zeitpunkt des Verkaufs einen gewissen Qualitäts
stand den sie im Idealfall ihrer Produktionskette auch immer ordentlich gesichert haben und sicherlich magst du auch noch andere Anbieter geben aber sicherlich jetzt auch keinen Fehler zu behaupten das Abus schon so eine Marke ist die ein gewisses Vertrauen im Markt.
Genossen hat oder vielleicht eben auch noch genießt und da haben sie natürlich dann auch über die erzählt die ihre Prozesse aufgebaut jetzt,
sehen Sie das ist sicherlich ja auch nachvollziehbar amove na ja was,
was ist unser Selbstverständnis als Unternehmen eher sind wir in Schlösser Hersteller ja oder verkaufen wir Sicherheit
also wahrscheinlich zum Schluss gekommen ja wir verkaufen halt Sicherheitssysteme so das waren bisher halt Schlösser aber jetzt gibt es eine neue Dimension und dann passen dann eben auch Kamerad bzw generell halt elektronische Systeme rein.
Und haben daneben ihr Portfolio um so ein Produkt erweitert.
Weiß halt quasi in den Kunden Zuschnitt passt oder ihr,
Portfolio entsprechend erweitert haben aber wahrscheinlich in dem Moment noch nicht vollständig verinnerlicht was das eigentlich für die für das Funktionieren und die Struktur Ihres Unternehmens bedeutet weil jetzt ein Sicherungs Prozess,
nicht etwas ist was nur bis zu dem Verkauf dieses Produktes stattfindet ja und im Wesentlichen sich auf eine Produktion bezieht daneben das jetzt in einer elektronischen Welt man eben,
einerseits eben auch über einen deutlich aufwendigeren Support für das Produkt über die Lebenszeit und,
im Idealfall natürlich auch noch deutlich darüber hinaus zu sorgen hat sondern eben auch sicherstellen muss dass einem diese Produktionsmittel um genau das auch durchführen zu können nicht Abhandenkommen
genau das ist ja hier passiert ja sie stellen auf einmal fest und will noch nicht mal in der Lage eine eigenes hoffe herzustellen also selbst wenn wir das sozusagen geglaubt hätten dass wir uns soweit schon verinnerlicht hätten dass wir in einem Sicherheit
der ist gegebenenfalls irgendwann mal zu Verfügung stellen müssen haben sie ja noch nicht mal dafür Sorge getragen also in ihren ganzen
Qualitätskontrolle und Qualitätssicherung vollständig übersehen dass ihr eben auch ein Prozess haben müssen um sicherzustellen dass überhaupt
tun zu können und das ist sicherlich eine Botschaft die bei einigen Unternehmen.
Jan wenn ich sogar vielleicht Monaten und Wochen auch schlagen dürfte das ist sich
dieses nicht reicht sich einfach mal Technologie von irgend so einem chinesischen oder taiwanesisch and Hersteller mal kurz einzukaufen und dann ist man am Markt warum muss halt eigene Expertise aufbauen und muss irgendwie Mitarbeiter haben die diesen Prozess,
kennen und im Idealfall sollte man vielleicht auch das ein oder andere selber herstellen und nicht einfach nur einkaufen wenn man wirklich an diesem Markt präsent sein möchte.
So dann haben wir.
Twitter Sperrungen das ist ja auch was Schönes wer also was was geschah bisher wären das netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz bekommen wo es darum ging irgendwie Menschen vor.
Vorfall vor
vor Beleidigungen oder sonstigen zu schützen wir haben die uploadfilter gerade wir haben auch einen Kodex zur Verhinderung von Wahlbeeinflussung der irgendwie Facebook Twitter und sonstigen abgerungen wurde ich habe erst gestern,
im Spiegel wieder so eine Tage ist in the blood Filme Anzeige gesehen Facebook schützt jetzt die Wahl ja da kommen wir später noch mal zu.
Bei all diesen bei All solchen Maßnahmen steht aber immer wieder im Raum was ist das Missbrauchspotential gerade beim netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz haben wir gesagt,
Pass auf das wird am Ende missbraucht nämlich die Löschung der Unfall von dem Wege geht die Löschung.
Die Tendenz das haben wir immer kritisiert weil.
Das Missbrauchspotential zu hoch ist beim netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz wo gesagt würde ok beanstandete Äußerungen müssen innerhalb von 24 Stunden gelöscht werden sonst Strafe für den für den Netzanbieter.
Das bedeutet natürlich dass die Tendenz und die Motivation für den Anbieter da hingeht im Zweifelsfall lieber zu löschen wenn aber daneben im Zweifelsfall lieber gelöscht wurde zu Unrecht dann ist ein Schaden entstanden für,
die betroffene Person der Löschung und Schaden für die Meinungsfreiheit sowas was beobachten wir jetzt gerade.
Menschen werden.
Prominente Menschen die eigentlich jetzt erstmal nicht als besondere hey da bekannt sind werden von Twitter gelöscht ist ging in meiner Wahrnehmung los mit Thomas Stadler der am 8. März 2016,
ja 2016 das ist also über drei Jahre her gezwitschert hat dringende Wahlempfehlung für alle AFD Wähler.
Unbedingt den Stimmzettel unterschreiben mit einem kleinen Smiley dahinter.
Wohlwissend dass wenn man seinen Stimmzettel unterschreibt der im Zweifelsfall ungültig wird und damit ist es eindeutig natürlich ein Versuch.
Die war zu beeinflussen und wurde wurde dieser dieser Tweet wurde beanstandet und sein Account daraufhin gesperrt.
Was hat sich echt scharf ist seit drei Jahre später und dann wegen Wahlbeeinflussung sind relativ klar dass das hier eine Maßnahme ist die am Ziel vorbei geht.
Sawsan chebli schrieb auf Twitter servicetweet an die AFD wir werden schon dafür sorgen dass dieser Name nie,
verschwindet es ging um den Namen Mohammed weil die AFD irgendwie,
wollte dass dir das dieser Name nicht mehr so oft vergeben wird auch dafür wurde sie.
Dann von Twitter gesperrt und dann wurde auch noch der Account der jüdischen allgemeine gesperrt die irgendwie.
Die die Aussage des israelischen Botschafters Isa acherhof.
Ja i Sacharow verbreitet hatte er meide den Kontakt zur AFD wegen deren Haltung zum Holocaust alles denke ich mal Äußerungen die sehr sehr klar,
im Bereich der der Meinungsfreiheit liegen sicherlich nicht im Bereich der.
Der Wahlbeeinflussung und alles Äußerungen die von Menschen getätigt wurden die sicherlich nicht besonders AFD nah sind.
Und es trifft sich ja also der Eindruck auf dass
die AFD oder ihre Sympathisanten diese Möglichkeiten sie zu melden hier spezifisch nutzen um liberal Account zu sperren und damit sind wir genau bei dem Missbrauchspotential vor dem,
wir immer gewarnt haben die werden jetzt glaube ich heute oder morgen
wird ein Vertreter von Twitter in den Bundestag geladen muss das dann da mal erklären wie sich das denn da vorstellen und wie sie meinen Meinungsfreiheit und,
Schutz vor Hitze und Schutz der Wahl irgendwie in Einklang zu bringen und es sieht gerade nicht so aus als hätten sie diese Sache nennenswert im Griff.
Ja es ist wirklich
absehbar mein Mann hat jetzt den Eindruck genauer wissen es natürlich nicht das bei Twitter also schon eine Menge getan wird technisch sozusagen um Missbrauch zu verhindern die Frage ist dann halt immer,
Wer missbraucht hier wen auf Basis welcher Regeln und wie wird das Ganze überprüft und es gibt die Möglichkeit halt so etwas zu melden so ein bisschen in der Annahme dass eben das nur Leute benutzen die irgendwie selber mit beiden Beinen
auf Recht und Gesetz stehen ja tatsächlich sehen wir das natürlich hier die Troll Armeen wieder einen Schritt weiter vorne sind und dieses Feature einfach benutzen
missliebigen Content zu markieren der daneben,
von Twitter genauso wird das Auf anderen Plattform stattfinden schnell entfernt wird weil könnte ja sein dass es stimmt
so und dann sind wir ja dafür belangt mit dem Ergebnis dass es alles noch schlimmer ist als vorher.
Jetzt sozusagen Twitter dazu benutzt andere Leute mundtot zu machen die Yavuz keinerlei Anlass und recht dafür gibt das zu tun.
Ich bin mal gespannt wie sieht das jetzt hoffentlich geklärt.
Ja dann gab's noch ein Hack.
Und zwar jetzt kommt die Russen wieder ne es gab einen Bericht,
der von einer,
Security Firma mit dem Vornamen Advance intelligence rausgebracht wurde also ein Blogpost ist es konkret wo sie darüber berichten dass eine so eine top tier Russian hacking and collective mit dem schönen Namen fx,
MSP offenbar Zugriff erhalten hat auf größere Teilmengen von Daten und das vermutlich
weil sie es geschafft haben in die Firmen Netze dieser Unternehmen einzubrechen
von Antiviren Herstellern aus den USA konkretes hiervon 3 Antiviren Herstellern die Räder da kann man sich jetzt mal überlegen welche ist denn da gibt ich glaube die Zahl ist gar nicht so groß
Mama können wir auch davon ausgehen dass ist er dir etwas populären Unternehmen getroffen hat aber wissen tun wir es nicht
die Advanced intelligence diese Firma meint aus den Daten soweit sie da ein Blick gehabt haben das schon ablesen zu können um wen es sich hierbei handelt auf jeden Fall werden diese Daten,
jetzt im Garten Untergrund feilgeboten für geschätzt 300000.
US-Dollar falls wenn man sozusagen Interesse hat an Daten dieser Unternehmen dann bräuchte man halt nunmal 300k offen
Tisch zu legen und dann könnte man eben diese Daten bekommen das sind wohl so irgendwie was in der Größenordnung von 30 Terabyte was
nach extrem viel klingenden hier sollen vor allem halt,
Quellcode von Programm also Antivirus-Programme aber auch so schien learning Algorithmen oder gezielte die ganz wie man heutzutage so schön sagt
Plugins für Browserschutz in ca all das soll in darin enthalten sein und man kann sich natürlich schnell vorstellen
was Desinteresse das originäre Interesse einer solchen Hacker Gruppe ist genau solche Unternehmen,
in das Fadenkreuz zu nehmen weil sie hat für dich dort ne ganze Menge Informationen darüber gewinnen können auch für sich selber.
Wie denn sozusagen die Software funktioniert die im Wesentlichen versucht solche Gruppen wie sie daran zu hindern das zu tun was getan haben und jetzt eben genau bei diesen Unternehmen,
ja das.
Weiß man nicht wer wer das ist es wird halt gemutmaßt dass es sich hierbei um eine russische Gruppe handelt und es wird auch gemutmaßt dass sie wohl bei dem Hack einer größeren Hotelgruppe
dahinter stecken sollen und ich vermute mal dass es sich dabei um den Hack dir mal auch hier schon neulich besprochen haben nämlich über deine Daten auch dabei waren den US ne.
Marriott.
Die Marriott Hotelgruppe handelt könnte,
ja also auch Antivirenhersteller die wirklich im Bereich Security ganz vorne sind haben offensichtlich ihre liebe Mühe ihre Netze zusichern mich richtig sehe ist das Ganze wohl über so remote access,
Roller und Active Directory Systeme entsprechende Bugs in diesen Systemen gelaufen das zumindest hier die Vermutung geäußert wird.
Ja also wenn die schon nicht sicher sind wer kann sich jetzt überhaupt noch sicher fühlen.
Ja wobei andererseits dass die gefährdet sind konnte man sich auch gut vorstellen ich meine weil die,
die eine Sache die eine Gruppe die diesen ganzen Malware Autoren irgendwie natürlich so der direkte natürliche Feind ist sind eben die
mayware Analysten die eben für Antiviren Arbeiten insofern kann ich mir schon vorstellen dass sie da sitzen und sagen yo die machen wir aber.
Die machen wir aber doch.
Aber die Bahn ja weil ich weiß gar nicht ganz genau
weil ich weiß jetzt nicht um wen es sich handelt aber ich vermute mal dass diese Unternehmen ja mittlerweile nicht nur Antivirus klassische Antivirus-Software in ihrem Portfolio haben soll natürlich auch solche intrusion-detection-system dir sozusagen vor genau solchen Angriffen schützen sollen und von daher ist es natürlich dann
dann putze ich dass sie leben trotzdem noch so ab
was ist aber es ist auch nicht so dass wir uns jetzt diese Illusion hergeben würden man wäre automatisch wenn man in dieser Branche arbeitet vor allem gefeiert weil wer weiß schon was die nächste Wahl durability ist jede Software die man im Einsatz hat kann theoretisch und ein Türchen aufmachen und man kann sich noch so sehr anstrengen
sprechen Architektouren und Prozesse dahinter zu machen wenn Software anfällig ist und zoofe ist anfällig
da kann das eben auch passieren dann muss man halt überlegen wie man eben seine Datenbestände noch mal weiter in tieferen Kaskaden versteckte wann hast du ja auch mal das Problem umso mehr du dann eben auch,
jeder hat deine eigenen Organisation ihr Zugriff auf die Daten
noch mal versucht sie da weitere Schutzmauern zustellen umso weniger umso komplizierter wird es natürlich auch innerhalb des Unternehmens an solche Informationen
Grad.
So
Facebook soll zerschlagen werden sagt niemand geringeres als Chris Hughes der diese Firma zusammen mit Mark Zuckerberg
gegründet hat Mitte der 2000er Jahre als sie noch zusammen innhavet studierten chris hat sein Studium beendet Mark Saka Berkeley.
Und ich bin sehr finde es sehr interessant wie er das nämlich sinnvoll vorträgt gesagt also.
Dass das Zerschlagen von groß zu großen marktbeherrschenden Konzern.
Eine gute gängige und sinnvolle Praxis im Kapitalismus ist um nämlich das was den Kapitalismus so toll machen soll nämlich der Wettbewerb
zu erhalten das wäre so sagen ok Kapitalismus Wettbewerb und so weiter ist nur solange gut wie wir keine marktbeherrschenden Einstellungen haben und wenn diese Marktwert einstellungen
leider früher oder später durch gegenseitiges aufkaufen erreicht werden dann müssen wir die Unternehmen wieder zerschlagen um das Positive
zu bewahren erzählt dann oft weil die Leute sagt sie haben jetzt Facebook ihren Facebook-Account gekündigt und machen nur noch Instagram was ich das wunderschöne Beispiel dafür ist dass man diesem Konzern kaum noch entkommen kann.
Bin mal gespannt wie viel Gehör er damit langfristig bekommt es war auf jeden Fall mal eine gewichtige Stimme wenn einer der.
Der ursprünglichen Unternehmensgründer daneben selber auftritt und sagt so bitte nicht.
Ist ja keine Zeit keine ganz neue Diskussion wird ja auch z.b. von Elizabeth Warren aktiv verfolgt gerade da in dem angehenden Präsidentschaftswahlkampf also diese Debatte existiert.
Diese Debatte wird auch vom Chaos Computer Club seit längerer Zeit
immer wieder ins ins Feld gebracht leider haben wir bisher noch nicht ein opinie npiece in der New York Times dafür bekommen mit eigens produzierten Video insofern will ich das hier als als Wandel der Zeit durchaus kurz erwähnt haben.
Dann ist eine weitere Darknet
Plattform erwischt und worden und hat gemacht worden dieses Mal traf es den Wallstreet market und der wurde betrieben von einem 31/31 jährigen aus Bad
Vilbel oder Bad Vilbel einem 29 Jährigen aus dem Landkreis Esslingen und einem 22 jährigen aus Kleve die nicht nur.
Offenbar diese Darknet Plattform da betrieben haben seine außerdem auch noch einen exit-scam planten exit-game geht so rum diese Darknet Plattform haben ja in der Regel so eine Art Escrow Service also sind.
Treuhänder Service und wenn dann Handelsvolumen groß genug ist dann kannst du dich auch zu jedem beliebigen Zeitpunkt einfach das Ding zu machen und die ganzen Bitcoins behalten und.
Es scheint dass sie davor hatten wir sehen hier wieder interessante Polizeiarbeit einerseits eine niederländische Spezial
Einheit die früher schon immer eine frühere Darknet Plattform infiltriert hatte und dann die an Misdroy
Karton überwacht hat und dann irgendwann diese werden diese Webseite selber betrieben hat und ihre Mitarbeiter gibt quasi,
dazu gebracht hat ihnen ihre Postadresse zu geben damit sie den irgendwie Hardware Security Module schicken könnten und so als teilweise Leute demaskiert haben desweiteren spielten hier aber,
zwei klassische Fehler der IT security anderer,
Thorsten und ich in unserem Vortrag behandelt haben auf dem 35 C3 mit dem Titel du kannst alles hacken du darfst dich nur nicht erwischen lassen.
Und insofern sind hier diese drei Leute in Deutschland am Ende von der Polizei hops genommen worden.
In Übereinstimmung mit unserer Prophezeiung erstens sie haben.
Bitcoin Wäsche versucht Bitcoin Wäsche geht so du also merkt sich ja in dem Glauben Bitcoin sei im anonym und das ist es ja auch so lange wie du dich so lange wie du keine,
Transaktion durchführst in deren Rahmen du deine Identität verraten musst wenn du aber dann wie einer dieser Betreibern.
Jan erstens eine Kette hinterlässt von einem 2016 geschlossenen Darknet Marktplatz der den Namen German Plaza market hat
und da mit 3000 Bitcoins raus gehst die damals ungefähr 1,2 Millionen Euro wert hatten heute glaube ich einiges mehr,
und damit den nächsten gründest dann nimmt er lässt du halt eine Spur und wenn du dann irgendwann mit deinem Kettcar
ausgerechnet bei einer gaming platform bezahlst wo du dann,
unter deinem Realnamen ein Konto pflegst und mit deinen kriminellen Bitcoins dort bezahlt dann,
passiert es eben das deine OpSec,
nexMart wie wir in unserem Vortrag außer schön sagen das heißt Bitcoins sammeln ist eine Sache wenn die die mit illegalen wegen sammelt dann müsst ihr euch überlegen wie ihr die jemals wieder gegen Geld tauschen könnt weil ihr dort in der Regel irgendwann,
Spuren zu eurer Identität hinterlasst das andere bevor wir gewarnt haben war die Verwendung von VPN.
Denn was VPNs neben den verschiedenen Arche.
Tour Schwächen das eben ihr dem VPN-Anbieter Vertrauen bist oder dass auch der VPN-Anbieter Besuch von der Polizei bekommen kann und das vielleicht,
viele Leute in Deutschland das VPN nutzen sodass ihr wie beim paar Monate Timing correlation relativ klar ist dass ihr der einzige Nutzer dieses VPN seit der für den es infrage kommt dieser kriminelle zu sein.
Im Hamm VPNs außerdem teilweise den die blöde Eigenschaft dass sie ab und zu mal zusammenbrechen und wenn ihr dann nicht eure VPN-Router ordentlich konfiguriert habt
dann entfleucht da halt das eine oder andere,
ehemals anonyme Paket oder ehemals anonymisierte Paket von eurer echten IP raus und auch das wurde hier einem der Betreiber,
zum Verhängnis insofern interessant zu lesen.
Und unser Vortrag hier noch mal empfohlen und ich nenne diesen Vortrag immer so ein bisschen dass das Gegenstück zu.
Zu meinem timcon Vortrag wo ich ihm sagte wie man nicht gehackt wird und hier eben wie man beim Hacken nicht erwischt wird denn Hacken ist verhältnismäßig einfach und auch so eine Darknet Plattform zu,
bauen oder zu betreiben ist verhältnismäßig einfach sehr sehr sehr viel schwieriger ist es.
Das dauerhaft zu machen ohne erwischt zu werden und hier also eine erneuter Polizei Fahndungserfolg ohne dass wir ein mit einem IT Sicherheitsgesetz 2.0
drakonische Strafen und Überwachungsmaßnahmen für allerlei Internet Kram.
Erlauben und insofern herzlichen Glückwunsch hier an die Polizei und herzlichen Glückwunsch an alle,
die haben vorher schon unsere Vorträge gesehen haben und sich da vielleicht ein bisschen vorsichtiger verhalten mit dem Mist den sie im internet ab.
Dann.
Wollen wir natürlich keine Folge verstreichen lassen ohne kurz über den Stand von Julien Assange und Chelsea Manning aufzuklären,
Julian Assange hat jetzt erst mal 50 Wochen Haft in England bekommen für die Verletzung seiner Bale Auflagen ich glaube kautions Auflagen wäre der deutsche,
Begriff dafür wohin eben gesagt weil du bleibst hier mit der Fußfessel in dieser Grafschaft auf diesem Hof und er daneben abgehauen ist und dafür wurde ihm,
eine vodim jetzt eine Strafe geben finde ich interessant weil ich das damals schon sagte dass das.
Dass ich glaube dass er dafür eine Strafe gibt und ich glaube wir hatten damals zu Kommentar der meinte dem Drang nach Freiheit der 3 und 3A Freiheit steht nicht unter Strafe ich glaube aber dabei ging es um gefängnisausbrecher oder.
Richtig.
Hermed aber klar wenn du deine wenn du wenn der wenn du gerichtlich dazu verurteilt wirst zu Hause zu bleiben und du bleibst nicht zu Hause dann gibt's eben.
Verschärfung genau.
Weiterhin.
Von der breiten Öffentlichkeit gar nicht soviel rezipiert gibt's einen eine Veröffentlichung war netzpolitik.org wo.
Eine Brief veröffentlicht wird der offenbar an daniel Domscheit-Berg gesandt wurde von dem US-Justizministerium und zwar dem,
östlichen Gerichtsbezirk von Virginia,
der Staatsanwaltschaft der Vereinigten Staaten die sagte sehr geehrter Domscheit-Berg auf Ersuchen der Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika haben die deutschen Behörden um die Durchführung einer freiwilligen Wahrnehmung.
Gebeten.
Zu verschreiben ist an den Anwalt von daniel Domscheit-Berg und stammt aus dem März 2018 er wird dem wird ihm quasi Angeboten er möge sich doch
mal freiwillig hier vernehmen lassen
über seine Zeit bei Wikileaks und im Gegenzug für diese Freiwilligkeit würden Sie für Strafverfolgung.
Für auf Strafverfolgung für alles verzichten mit dem er sich der quasi selber belastet und da steht aber dann drin dass sie gegen den,
Julian Assange wegen des unerlaubten Erhalts und der Verbreitung geheimer Informationen.
Und darauf steht in den USA als Höchststrafe.
Die Todesstrafe und das ist natürlich aus verschiedenen Gründen interessant weil,
wenn die Todesstrafe droht dann dürfen die UK ihn.
Nicht ausliefern.
Und das ist natürlich jetzt nicht ohne besondere Relevanz und zeigt ja auf deren diesen Verdacht ja immer hier schon,
vorsichtig geäußert dass wir davon ausgehen dass die USA noch eine ganze Menge anderer Ermittlungsverfahren und Strafen,
für Julien Assange in der Schublade haben als die nur öffentlich behauptete er hat Chelsea Manning Angeboten ein Passwort zu knacken,
ohne das übermittelt ist ob der Tauber damit überhaupt erfolgt gleichzeitig.
Ist Schweden wieder aufgewacht wir erinnern uns in Schweden wird Julien Assange beschuldigt,
einmal eine Frau zum ungeschützten Sex genötigt zu haben und,
zweitens eine andere Frau im Schlaf vergewaltigt zu haben diese Beschuldigung stammen wenn ich mich nicht täusche aus dem Jahr 2010 und,
seit 2012 war Julien Assange in der Botschaft Ecuadors und wir haben über Jahre dann beobachtet die er.
Quasi sich der.
Alter Vernehmungen in indem Innenräumen der Botschaft sehr offen gegenüber gezeigt hat aber der Idee.
Nicht unbedingt angeht nicht vondir.de angetan war in nach Schweden zu reisen weil er befürchtet Edward verhaftet und dann an die USA ausgeliefert.
Die Untersuchungen wurden.
Zweites ersten Falles wurden 2015 eingestellt einfach weil das verjährt ist ja dass ihm vorgeworfene zwingen zum nötigen zum ungeschützten.
Sex der andere Fall wo es um Vergewaltigung geht der ist nicht verjährt und der wurde aber da wurden die Ermittlungsverfahren eingestellt weil.
Die schwedische Staatsanwaltschaft gesagt hat okay der Fall der sperrt sich hier gegen die Vernehmung.
Und jetzt wo er aber quasi wieder aus dieser Botschaft raus ist und den britischer Haft ist wurde auch dieses Verfahren wieder aufgenommen.
Die Frist für diesen Fall läuft im August 2020 aus erst am Ende seiner Haftstrafe in Großbritannien könnte er daneben.
An in an Schweden ausgeliefert werden das wäre im Oktober ja also wird jetzt spannend Schweden bliebe daneben von Oktober bis.
Bis März nur wenige Monate bis August 2020 etwas weniger als ein Jahr um diesen Fall dann irgendwie abschließend zu bearbeiten.
Das ist also da ist jetzt also noch nicht alles geklärt wir werden sehen was die USA da jetzt noch Vorbringen wir werden sehen was das Auslieferungsersuchen der USA angeht wir werden sehen was das Auslieferungsersuchen Schwedens angeht und ich bin mir sicher das werden wir noch in weiteren Folgen
dann im Detail.
Aufdröseln vor allem wie die Abhängigkeit dieser Fälle zueinander ist und ich will mir sicher dass da dann auch noch mal neben der rechtlichen Bewertung eine der die willkürlichen Rahmen der Entscheidung in Großbritannien.
Eine Rolle spielen werden gute Nachricht Schatzi Menning wurde aus den,
Knast entlassen für dieser Freilassung also wir erinnern uns Siwa red ich glaube etwas über 40 Tage in Beugehaft weil sie gesagt hat dass sie vor dieser Grand Jury eben die Aussage verweigert.
Und jetzt ist die Amtszeit dieser Grand Jury ausgelaufen aus diesem Grunde wurde sie jetzt freigelassen
sie hat aber quasi schon die neue Aufforderungen zum 16. Mai das ist morgen vor der
vor der neuen Grand Cherry Aussagen es ist also davon auszugehen ist also denkbar dass sie bereits morgen,
am 16. Mai wieder in Haft muss weil sie eben auch schon klar gesagt hat dass sie auch dieser zweiten Aufforderungen vor der Rente re,
auszusagen keine.
Folge leisten wird gleichzeitig olabi nie über den wir hier auch berichtet haben und weiterhin berichten werden.
Ist nach wie vor in Ecuador in Haft schreibt fleißig Briefe und da haben wir natürlich die,
wie ich nicht müde müde werden möchte zu betonen die noch sehr viel Ekel ihre Situation denn so,
willkürliche die USA handeln so.
Schwer nachvollziehbar Großbritannien hier streckenweise handelt haben wir immer noch gut gepflegte Rechtssysteme mit langen bürokratischen.
Bei Prozessen.
In Ecuador fehlt gerade ein ganz anderer Wind und der Fall von Ola Beanie darf da nicht unsere Aufmerksamkeit verlieren deswegen wären wir der nächsten Folge noch mal ausführlicher drüber sprechen.
Damit zu tun ob ich dann Ende der Sendung.
Damit kommen wir ans Ende der Sendung am Ende der Sendung bleibt uns immer nur noch kurz der Dank.
Ich danke Jan Sven und Margret und ich weiß dass ich hier zwei.
Personen vergessen habe die sicherlich auch wissen dass wir bei der LMP 300 miteinander gesprochen haben und ich würde mich freuen wenn ihr euch.
Dann kurz bei mir melden könnte dass ich euch auch noch entsprechend.
Und wir danken natürlich auch allen direkten und regelmäßigen Spendern der Metaebene und von logbuch-netzpolitik
und wir bedanken uns auch dass ihr es wieder mal über zwei Stunden hier mit uns ausgehalten habt und.
Jetzt geht's auch wieder weiter nach dem eine kleine Pause nehmen mussten und hoffen euch auch künftig wieder wöchentlich versorgen zu können.
Oder mach aber da muss ja muss ja wieder deutsche sagt muss ja also mach's gut bis bald tschüss.